[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
my check on a Sunday
[Music]
sound good
especially young dreads what's up Zach
Riley says
you know I told you I was gonna take a
little break from the Starfield my dumb
ass right back oh you went right back
yeah
oh and I see what people are talking
about man the story is different oh okay
easy easy on the spoilers easy on the
spoilers what about now um
I really really
[Music]
it feels good to be back I'm blessed
I've been through a lot I'm not supposed
to be here but
um yeah I mean we here we're here so
we're going to take our blessings and uh
like I said it's an unfortunate
situation but we got through it and uh
yeah we're gonna have some fun we're
gonna do what we do and uh I can't wait
to talk to y'all let's go be a fun show
and uh yeah all right y'all so what
we're gonna do we're gonna get all
people to introduce
I think that's what it is too but um
once the show starts appreciate
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
am look y'all messed up and turned me to
an animal and headers be swearing ain't
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social knowing my city but I'm
still by Coastal I got you man
[Music]
that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social lower my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my CD but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start it regardless with messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter at a man time social or my city
but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
hell look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but coming to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social knowing my city but I'm
still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
um
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rains you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start with regardless back
when you with messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back weed with
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social but
I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell a uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all feel Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns uses the target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social lower my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack
[Music]
too much more time
I'ma just chill and watch them and he
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if I can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cause if you don't
give her that option you're gonna be
single player like siren you're gonna
get tossed in the bushes by King David
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental what's an avatar to an
even though I gotta be me though I know
it's my destiny work to carnido who
cares if he flies you stealing mosquito
you swear you ain't nothing but really
be Stevo you like to collect stuff and
that's cool but I got bad news even if
he really was that joke he ain't never
still be the king of the statue sister
juvenile I've been cursed with a curse
to be Musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in The Crucible other than nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord day
[Music]
radio
mama do Factor right and the Mike's hot
yeah hello hello
I ain't loads without a hot mic
hold on a second we missing the bottom
ball hit man we didn't pay the bill for
the bottom ball what's going on
we're not we're not that well funded
yeah then we got the old
Lord addict sir
hello hello oh nice and quiet
no hiss no way
it's on though it's wiggling it's
wiggling no it's wiggling baby
like I I guess my speakers when they
were like acting up they would they
would like make my whole computer be
messing up so yeah now I don't have
speakers
Elgato white crispy in the corner yeah
and then I got a Starkville poster too
oh very nice
good looking awesome controller
a lot of branding a lot of guns
yeah that's what I heard
that dudes don't want to show these
faces
Microsoft doesn't know how to Market
anything another scene basically
I mean
clearly kids movie was the the leader of
that Movement we can't act like that
there wasn't a time where he's like yo
why ain't we seeing nah that was wrong
leader of the mustard being in the teams
we gotta let kid get his clap back
your mouth
yo they got buses they got trains they
taking over whole cities and look at
y'all now they got basketball courts
some dude said I don't care that's the
WN NBA and how many people seen it how
many people seen that star fell on that
floor looking good I like it's called
Mark and it's called spending your money
yeah
and we are live and welcome to the
island lunch podcast LLC and also live
on Lords of gaming.net episode number
320. uh quickly today is World Suicide
Prevention Day tell a friend tell a
relative acquaintance you haven't spoken
to a while give them a hug just tell
them you love them um you know
everyone's at some point is probably
going through something and also rest in
peace to the homie um Lord whiskey or
whiskey so I wouldn't have said some
love and uh also it is a glorious Sunday
we're back reunited at the round table
on the Lord's day and today we've got
Starfield successful launch week
PlayStation Plus price increase
switch to rumors hold on wait a second
you said wait a second I was doing
something you said what what was the
second topic it was
PlayStation Plus price increase
thank you sir switch to rumors and E3
future to discuss so we're gonna get
right into it so let's introduce the
Four Horsemen of gaming those original
Lords and gaming Knights of the realm
here at the round table my co-host
Nicole Mouse my brother from another
mother the difficult game conqueror Lord
of his own world and the how of the
young wolf my man Lord attic back to
back from the attic show how we doing
doing pretty good uh you know first
thing I want to point out some games
I've been playing I've actually been
playing uh a lot of they they
Mario uh rabbits the Mario rabbits spark
of hopes they actually have a DLC with
Raymond in it oh Raymond I remember yeah
and it's kind of funny
man
Everybody Loves Raymond yeah but
um it's an interesting DLC man I I
definitely if you got the game I would
recommend trying it out you know they
they he's he actually switches abilities
because obviously it's turn based uh so
what he does is like he'll switch to
like his lightning suit or his win suit
and you can like ride a rocket and hit
people like it's it's a pretty fun time
another thing I want to talk about real
quick is like yeah and I'm sure you know
especially King and Saul can relay on
this is like how good of a game sea of
stars is couldn't really talk about it
because we weren't here last week and
the week before that I was still under
cargo so I couldn't really comment too
much on it but that is definitely like
you know how they usually give like an
indie game in there with Game of the
Year Contender like that would be my
game to go in there like that's how good
that game is like that game yeah is
fantastic and you know I recommend
everyone you know that
there's no reason you can't play that if
you like those old style turn-based
games like Chrono Trigger it doesn't
matter what platform you play on
there is a place for you to play it if
you on PC there's the Windows store if
you want Xbox there's Game Pass if you
want PlayStation it's on PlayStation
Plus there is no reason yeah you can't
touch this game yeah
they don't play games they play x man
they don't care about that RPG that turn
blade that's capping stuff
they need 60 frames they need polygons
they need story driven games
and you know I I really enjoyed it I
think you guys would
appreciate that game especially you know
people that like those old style RPGs I
got a question what and it pertains
specifically about this game somehow I
feel like it is but it's not going
yes well okay so I've started this game
four times already right so when I came
back from Seattle I was like yo let me
just jump on and just play on my Xbox
now I was playing a ton on the flight on
my rock yeah you don't do that and then
um
I I don't it's not transferring my saves
over so I need help oh that's it I don't
want to start all over again oh all you
got to do is um yeah you gotta you gotta
put your wireless back on right if we
log into your uh what you call your
sister are you playing from the the
GamePad which which version of
superstars you play you're playing some
game pass or Steam I'm playing game pass
now okay there you go I don't think Game
Pass has cross-play
I don't have the data
it's a game pass game right yeah right
yeah no it definitely has if it's in
game pass this should work it should
work automatically the moment you load
up your but what it is is he never low
he I'm assuming King you've never played
it on you never started on Console first
if I no correct correct so you started
on PC game pass first right so all you
got to do is now you get home turn your
Wireless on on your rock I'm assuming it
was disabled yeah turn it on and then
from there log in on your Rog to what
you call it before during the login
process you're gonna see syncing data
it's going to say you're gonna see an
Xbox thing in the back syncing data
whatever whatever and then from there
once you do that do a hard save oh and
then from there then go to console oh so
you're saying because he was on air yeah
he's playing offline and saving it local
to the device okay so he never uploaded
it to the cloud that's what is what
happened no problem yeah and then once
you do that that over if there's a game
pass or it's a Windows play Anywhere
that's not in Game Pass you Gucci yeah
no I did not want to start that up
six hours of work
yeah it's a great game man I really
enjoyed it it it's got a lot of good
stuff going for it you know if this year
wasn't so stacked I would say it's
guaranteed to be in the Game of the Year
Contender list well it's an RPG of the
year a contender for sure yeah
definitely uh but as far as like the
game of the year thing but man it's just
such a stacked year like it uh you know
they all the only games I consider like
being in there for sure is like Zelda
and like breath uh Zelda and and
boulders gate three like that's how
stacked this year I'm looking forward to
this year this year
I'm looking forward to gay or the game
of the year competition this year
somebody got to go down
it's going down somebody somebody
[Laughter]
last night I would absolutely love the
Starfield one game of the year it's a
seven nothing
no that would that that would be
interesting the fires would burn like
Twitter would be so quick for the chaos
it would be funny yes it would be fun
absolutely all right they will they will
be on some other platforms it's a new
platform for you we got like six bro we
got a strong content this is weird yeah
I mean it's the year work but one bro
it's the year it's the year where I I
feel like
something's about to get like shoved out
oh hold up shout out to the homie Jeff
grubby grub up in there church I gave it
is six who knew
again a lot of people love it yeah but
here's the thing like is this the year
that they push out
you can't make that face no like that
like like that's out of bounds
and did a hard two days of talking it
was like yeah I'm a call yeah all right
hey boys yo shout out to giant ball man
we pulled up we pulled up full we wanted
to show Unity brother it was a pleasure
down his back
he wasn't feeling buried
that's why I didn't take a picture with
him oh my God you was disgusted that you
you didn't you didn't get the full
experience
all right so you know how girl they
coming at you you know when when they
say yo Jesus is over there in that town
so you get up with it and Jesus got a
ball head come on
Jesus
was doing false advertising on his head
so it's like Samson and Delilah right
you got over there after Delilah got a
hold of him that's fine don't come for
my man so listen so grubby grub um I'm
gonna take a picture with you you next
uh next grow your hair back and then
so I got there and he had on a Mario
suit and um I was like oh man yeah he
shout out to the crew they had a good
paddle
too oh and I was messing with miles
miles yeah miles is so cool anyway
it's a good game I I recommend all of
you guys trying it out like I said it's
on everything uh you know we went to Pax
West last week and it was definitely a
uh a fun experience you know met people
like Jeff Grubb ironically for short
hair yeah that's short hair grub
it was it was a good time man it was a
good time
Pax West was a an experience to say the
least we'll talk a little bit more about
it and of course we have our most
technical gaming Lord the solo game who
lives for the single player selfish
experience and also the substradamus the
Lord of clarity and Lord patreon of the
iron bank PC Master races oh Lord
Sovereign how are we doing sir I'm good
I'm about to be joined in that room I
like that
yeah he talking a lot but it's cool
anyway
uh let me apologize in advance now
because I'll be having to dip out early
because as I've said many times before
my life hates me
[Laughter]
my wife my wife adores me my life though
my life acts like I did something bad to
it for real so yeah I'll be dipping out
a little bit early today so apologies in
advance but uh otherwise doing good been
playing I don't know that I don't know
if you guys have heard
this is there's a game that I've been
playing
um
foreign
in some people's minds but I am
thoroughly enjoying it for all the
foolishness that I can do now I got a
question for y'all so we're having this
discussion about how you can't get
Contraband once you're up in the air and
you go back you know into UC space how
do you do it so this is what and again I
don't know if this has been solved or
whatever but for me I was thinking okay
if you go into your ship and just drop
the Contraband in your ship meaning it's
not on your person it is not in your
storage at all does it does it register
as being on the ship it does I don't I
was gonna try this because I'm like okay
I have I have a few pieces of Contraband
that are very they have they're worth a
lot yeah value I'm like okay how do I
get this here and this that and the
other so that I was thinking about some
Kaka made me think about going around a
different direction you know but once
you get to uc's face you're in trouble
so I was thinking maybe if I drop it and
it's not in my person and the game would
not recognize
unless you have a shielded cargo like
they're gonna see it every time well
that's the thing though okay so there's
a thing where you can Shield the cargo
yeah somebody's they say go to the
wolves and so they said go to the dance
off that's what it keeps there's a
couple places you could get it too you
can also get it and the Crimson Fleet uh
but you know it you'll buy pretty much
anything in your your cargo will be
shielded and they won't be able to see
it or you can buy the signal Jammers too
oh okay where they they mess up on
accident there's a lot of difference
there's a lot of stuff that you can do
in the game they got a seven yeah
talking strategy or how to sneak stuff
in a planet that's kind of crazy that
must be some wild AI I haven't heard
about that in Boulder's Gate oh this is
what I started doing right because I
told you I'm always encumbered right I
always so I was like you know what
everything that I want I yeah I've taken
that so I haven't found the drugs that
allow me to just rock out with like a
thousand pounds of stuff on me but uh I
just decided to start dropping
everything in my [__] so like the upper
level of my [__] you see the stuff
yo the physical will disappear
eventually oh really eventually yeah so
but it's just fun to see it there and
then you know if I need something really
I go back oh I can't dig through this
sift through the rubble to try to yeah
it has like a a hoarder's house ship
from yeah of stuffing cats Stoppers
horde house
so uh that's been fun that's been fun
but again I'm gonna start going more
towards the story because I've done a
lot of messing around going to planets
and stuff like that like you know what
let me let me start
focusing on the story that everybody's
talking about so because I don't want to
get spoiled and I already got spoiled on
some stuff that is fairly early in game
but because of how I played I just
haven't gotten there so I'm like oh whoa
what what's this so I'm like nah let me
not let me stop that get it get a couple
of constellation get a couple of them in
yeah so I I've done I've done like two
constellation missions I'm like all
right you're gonna like get to like the
fourth or fifth one yeah you're gonna be
like there's a point that that like I
got you and I'm like okay now I see why
people are saying yeah there's a point
where you're gonna be like oh oh that
part is nice but at the same time I I
feel like it's a tale of two people
playing this game it's you guys that
follow the rules and then it's us guys
that'd be like no I'm talking about
that's how I normally play but that's
the games I don't normally care about I
couldn't tell you how what was the main
thing in Skyrim I did I always like all
right what's up with this guy
by far the best single player story
they've ever yeah the story is crazy
it's not even close like and it's not
like I think some of you said it best on
what I think it was you yeah oh you were
Nick it may have been Nick yeah from the
Lord's game where it's like it's not one
of them joints where it feels fake
because you know I like most games we
like the main quest save the world or
else because it's not that because you
know I'm gonna go over here and be a
Fighters girl like it's this is so
relevant and it works together it works
together yeah it's not one of those
where it's like oh the world's about to
blow up but I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
this way yeah trust me yeah and it's
addicting
not not gonna spoil anything but I will
say after actually getting into Game
Plus
Starfield handles New Game Plus better
than any other game I've ever seen yeah
so nice Okay and like like Alex said sea
of stars as well um whoa bro if you are
a fan if you're a fan of Corona trigger
if you're a fan of Final Fantasy VI uh
all the all the the essays I don't know
if you notices so do you know that's in
the message uh the the messenger
Universe yes
in the universe I heard the next game is
supposed to do a collab yo this I mean
it is so good it's such a beautiful game
the characters it's one thing like when
you really love all the characters
that's a special thing because when it
comes down to like moments that you
decisions have to be made and and it's
like man I you don't you love them all
yeah and it is that type of game where
you love them all and then when it comes
to the combat I've always loved those
games that it started to incorporate
like button presses and time button
presses with parries and counters and
allowing you to to hit twice and get you
know get double the damage points on an
enemy stuff like that so you're always
engaged and so it's it's turn based but
you're always engaged and it feels more
active because you always have to be
paying attention to the animations of of
the enemies and stuff like that when and
sometimes they they'll change up the
animations mid-fight you think a certain
thing is coming and then they'll either
attack a different party member or
they'll attack in a different way and
all of a sudden your timing's off and
you can't do that parry and and then you
get rocked right it's stuff like that
that for a game like this right I come
from that time right that time period so
I love games like this but maybe
somebody knew who hasn't played these 2D
type of RPGs or classic jrpgs and you're
like um they turned off by it right it's
like oh it's not polygons it's not Final
Fantasy you know whatever 16 or 7 remake
whatever
that type of stuff gameplay wise is so
engaging that it hooks you it hooks you
and then it allows you to really
appreciate the story and the characters
it is a special special game and like
addict said like if it wasn't such a
crazy packed year oh my God this is
guaranteed in the game of the year
because yeah if they do if it's true and
they do try to give you know a indie
game in that round I could totally see
that and you're not to mention I I where
I beat it too like it's got a great
story like if if I didn't know any
better and I didn't know I would say
Square made this back in the 90s it's
that kind of game it's very very good
yeah
um what you call the writers that did
that so yeah and then of course a big
shout out to everybody that we got to
hang out with at Pax West it was a good
time yep Seattle was a was a definitely
a different vibe than it uh the Boston
in Boston a lot of different walking
around a little bit different even to to
when you know Cog went because they
added another yeah
it was a little it was a little weird
running back and forth but it was it was
great to hang out with everybody but we
got to sit down and break bread with
thank you so much it was it was a very
very good time and got to see a you know
like I said a lot of faces that I hadn't
met in person before so that was very
cool so uh again looking forward to it
to doing it again any standout games sir
from Pax West ah the pizza Bandit for me
um so we so so Cog was doing an
interview with uh um right next to this
to the station and the interview was uh
about sort of like a was it a Chinese
like Kung Fu base like yeah pixel pixel
art jrpg right
um and I was standing there watching the
interview [__] was doing it I think uh
AJ was playing I uh attic was playing
and King was recording so I was just
kind of in the cut now look behind me
and I see this crazy looking third
person action game kind of in the vein
of like a gears or something like that
just Bonkers like shooting and very very
smooth fluid movement and I look at the
time it was like pizza Bandit I'm like
okay this is like completely ever right
if there ever was a misnomer I'm like
this is it
um and so immediately we didn't have an
appointment right and thank you know
the the power of the past so it allows
you to sort of um we went in and like
hey man we're gonna want to have an
interview with you guys while you're
playing yeah I mean and we you know and
they they were amenable to that so I
appreciate that and we were able to jump
in immediately after uh cog's interview
and we we did uh Pizza Bandit and that
game
um what did he call it a monster hell
game so it is kind of a bullet hell game
but with monsters
um it is a third person action game it
has only been in development four or
five months and at this point it is
super smooth fluid it is built in unreal
um they're in unreal four right now
they're transitioning to five and
they're looking to have the game out by
sometime middle middle to the back end
of next year
um and when you see the level of Polish
this game has from just a couple of
months in development it's kind of
Bonkers
um but it's a third person action
shooter it is super difficult apparently
the main Dev of the game
is a former pro player so he's like I'm
about the difficult game so it's it's
not an easy game so
um yeah so look out for pizza Bandit and
and so we asked him why the name Pizza
Bandit and he gave me a thing I
completely forgot what it was but he did
tell me there was at one point there was
a mini game in the um in the game where
you're making pizza with your girlfriend
while enemies are coming at you so I
don't know if that is the the Crux of
why it's called pizza man there's
probably more to it but maybe he's a
pizza delivery guy that kind of like got
caught up in the middle of this demon
apocalypse or something like that yeah
because it's just basically like a demon
apocalypse that came out of nowhere and
this guy's just blasting demons but um
it is it looks like a fun time really
really good so that's that's what really
stood out to me and of course so we got
to play some Tekken eight
that is a ue5 show piece for sure yeah
it's so good to see you and now shout
out to the game that was next to Pizza
better that's how you found it was what
is it the world of kung fu
addict covered it with me and um real
passionate devs they're still working on
the localization I believe it's going to
be on Steam but it's going to come in on
all major platforms kind of in that sea
of stars vein jrpg but with you know
Kung Fu movesets and it looked really
cool they were super bad that team was
super scary this gameplay is more like
uh tell me how you know uh Fire Emblem
oh yes yes thank you yes yeah yes
absolutely so that's itself that's it
that's it and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the access
gamer the prophet and Morpheus of Xbox
one king of the statues there is nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the leader of the whole the live
movement
beloved came to see my boy the Hazmat
suit Lord King how you doing
I'm doing better than uh alisanya oh I
was a child oh no wait oh b-o-b yeah
um
yesterday that you know yeah he's wants
to show up like Spence
must have been on the same side I'm
gonna send you something break your
heart I'm gonna send you something that
you gonna go I cannot believe that
they must have been on the same stuff
because he looked this interested not
himself and he couldn't keep Pace he
couldn't catch Pace he couldn't I don't
know I just he did not look like out of
Sonya like if that was going to be the
first time that you saw a style Bender
you're gonna walk away from that
thinking that that's not it and then and
it just so wasn't so I don't know
um I don't know if it's gonna be a
rematch I don't know what's going on I
look like it's gonna be yeah so I don't
know it's it was disheartening to see it
it felt like I wasted my time watching
it yesterday I went to go see Strays
there's a movie out there called Strays
is he checking I mean check or IOP uh
chat stuff I got you
um do not do not take your children to
go see Strays I repeat oh yes and that
is not a children there isn't me you see
cute dogs I'm telling you now do not do
it is not what you want to do if you
don't want uh child services to come to
your house
that is I took my kid to see this he
wouldn't talk about this child services
is at my house that's it that's a moment
don't do that dope movie
um what I've been playing oh no no for
first and foremost
all right uh just a quick address of
addressment of some stuff yeah
when we find out that we go into these
events right uh let's say we find out
five months ahead of time we're going to
go to Pax we schedule everything from if
you see us uh having dinner with
somebody or lunch with somebody all at a
schedule
from the moment we uh get the the okay
that we're gonna go to like a Pax and we
put in for our media credentials from
that moment we are planning we are
planning the flights because all of us
have jobs so we're planning that time
we're um scheduling around the family or
whatever and then we're scheduling
each and every last second from when we
land to how we meet up to going to the
hotel
to uh making sure we charge our
batteries making sure that what's the
first uh meetings that we have and being
that we're a team of four we usually
split up of tool tools and that schedule
is broken down to that all the way to
lunch and to who we're going to see at
that period of time so everything is
pretty much scheduled right
um at no point in time do we take
anything for granted because we're
always looking to Bulldog a new
interview so what bulldog in a new
interview is if we have any free time
whatever we see from the corner of our
eye that intrigues us we go and we try
to Bulldog the interview get the
interview there that's the interview
without a schedule so we're trying to
fill whatever gaps that we do have with
more information because we have writers
waiting for the website before we push
that stuff up right now
during this whole period of time before
we even get to the event we're putting
on our social medias the Lord's is going
to packs the Lords is going to packs and
if anybody that is in our circumference
like a um uh podcast that we talked to
we try to you know and not to tell
everybody that we're going and we would
hope in community that the community
would do the same like oh you go in the
packs I'm going to packs so that maybe
we can meet up at Pax and try to do
something a little bit different could
you imagine like I did did a video with
uh Colt myself and we was talking about
phone stars but that happened
organically because he was there and
while we was going there he texted me yo
I'm here and we can meet up right now
don't ever take anything as a slight
that if you see us moving in traffic and
if we feel like if you seem like we're
moving too fast and we don't take time
to acknowledge you or something like
that it's not done
out of purpose is not done out of we
felt that we've made it someplace
because we we haven't made it anywhere
okay we have 20 000 subs and we are
grateful for everything and every time
we go to these shows we go to it as a
new show every show is the first show
it's not it's not we've made it anywhere
and we don't prioritize who we take
pictures with we take pictures with
everybody and last time I checked
everybody has a phone so if I didn't ask
for a picture or I didn't see a picture
maybe I was so caught up in the moment
that I was having fun in the moment and
I just detached myself from the social
media aspect of it and was just having
fun and vibing with friends
I feel that
um if at any point in time that you
something is missing on my part bring it
to my awareness uh especially if it's
like a picture of something you see me
and don't ever be afraid to like if you
see me oh that's king or I don't want to
bother him right now you are not
bothering facts all right and also if I
do make time if I if I do get a chance
to squeeze you in that meant that you
were super important that meant that you
were important enough for me to find
time in that busy schedule to to make
importance to see you now
when we finish that day we go home yeah
we go right to the hotel and we go to
sleep
down on half days because I wasn't 100
oh yeah Carl couldn't be running around
I'm sorry but um attic and I'll be up
editing I was up editing and putting up
videos on Twitter if you go to my
Twitter check it out that whole night
and we left at five o'clock in the
morning I probably slept like an hour or
two
um because we got up at three to go to
the hotel uh to the airport but we we
don't go out we don't party so if it
looked like that that's not what that is
every second of going to these shows is
working and getting stuff up for you
guys so I just want to say if you felt
slighted you felt that we didn't make
any time for you or you wasn't
prioritized that's not the thing yeah we
didn't make it anywhere we're not
Hollywood we're not well funded we're
well uh Community yes for the community
we're not anywhere we're trying to do
our best to get everything back to you
all right past that what I've been
playing I've been playing a game that I
can't talk about but I'll be talking
about it after 11. yeah yeah um
such a fun game too
I've been playing Starfield see at the I
mean sea of stars
um uh days of Doom
that's about homing yeah Jason is it
turn based uh game it that game all
right stop it I I don't think I think
we're under NDA on that game days of
Doom we all yeah well we we could talk
we covered it we covered it yeah you
covered it we can't talk yeah
we talked about that I was playing in
the pack sweat sorry
um it was a dope game with Pax West
um
it was a cool turn-based game at pack
Splash that uh to be fair yeah we just I
just sent King the code I didn't tell
him or afford any kind of yeah we good
it was it was it was it's not that
serious he he making it like him but I
respect that what attic just did but um
no like we had covered it um again what
they had sent out reached out it was
like Hey Lord the third base we heard
again one of those organic things that
kind of happened during the course of us
being at an event we finally get a
chance to go over there I interviewed a
developer and um awesome he's actually
gonna solved he's been on um Collins oh
he had a second symbols plus with Colin
yeah it was really cool and um yeah from
the town from the town New York yeah
office whatever whatever so you can see
the I believe the producer on the
project you can see the energy and it
was cool because attic was doing in
gameplay while King was um doing the the
camera coverage and stuff while I'm
interviewing him and um attic was really
getting into it so it's kind of like uh
we would say like a turn-based meets uh
State of Decay kind of vibe and then
obviously you know King you know he's
really enjoying it as well so yeah all
four of the games that they had there
was dope all four of the Atari going to
an Atari booth in 2023 is nuts so
playing that and
um just having a real fun time with with
starfish someone said stop snitching at
it
it's all good yeah it's it's like
equivalent to me letting King not
knowing talking about the stuff that we
have that comes out tomorrow
stop it guys
no no that's about it and oh we did a
show shout out to Ben yes Kenobi coming
up
um you know to hold the line coin that
uh you know we didn't collab and for
those 30 people that actually got one um
you're part of something different
something a moment it's a moment in
history like you know when The Rock went
on stage with uh Bill Gates and you know
or when Peter Moore told Alexa talk for
us you know Peter Moore aggregated
extent with his tattoo on ridiculous you
know um but uh this moment is it's a fun
moment for us and we're all part of it
so everybody that got partaking it you
know got your congratulations guys that
y'all got your coin then did a great job
no doubt and of course we have me every
time uh Shinobi Lord Cognito spreading
that real into the Roman IOP now tell me
what you want to hear but what you need
to hear um on a serious note you know I
want to thank everybody I've been really
going through a difficult time and um
for those who don't know I'm just going
to give the abbreviated version most of
the Lords of the realm of the Dukes know
but the realm of the Lords I don't think
I officially said that what went down so
um yeah pretty much
um about two three weeks ago you know I
was not feeling well you know I just
thought it was a typical flu it kind of
progressed on me very fast to the point
where you know it became a lot of muscle
pain my breathing was extremely labored
it took me about like um an hour to put
my socks on just to get from like the
couch to the to the living room from the
to the to the kitchen was just bad I
remember speaking of Atticus like bro
that sound like pneumonia and I was like
yeah something's going on so after the
450 and once the breathing was laboring
check myself into the ER so and actually
before that I actually uh tested myself
and my covet test came back negative so
didn't know what was going on so I just
uh you know checked myself in and uh
yeah immediately they ran a bunch of
tests immediately found out new strand
of covid and um affectionately called
Eris like like Destiny so I thought that
was interesting but um yeah it was it
was pretty bad you know I wasn't being
able I wasn't able to on my own and they
were like yeah you're not going home so
I was pretty much hospitalized for about
five days you know isolated off kind of
the funny part is they were so excited
to get a new covet vacation
that they were like oh we have it we go
we can't wait you know to do some stuff
and testing so pretty much it was a it
was a trifecta it was covet it was
pneumonia on top of it and then I
already had a pre-existing condition
with that verticulitis that came back so
I was fighting three things at once and
it was rough it was rough so uh shout
out to King shout out to the homies that
came to see me and um you know after
about day three or four I was able to
come off the oxygen and um yeah just
start to slowly recover and get better
so um you know during that bring in the
hospital you're never really resting you
know it's always three every two three
hours hey we gotta check this hey we're
gonna give you this IV for this we're
gonna do all this stuff but um the
sobering part was that you know after I
you know really recovered and you know
the doctor was like wow you really
turned around you're good you're good to
go you're gonna release you you know
they did give me some sobering Words
which was like hey
if you are not a healthy guy if you were
not a guy that was in shape this would
have killed you so at that point you
know the tears started running down and
I'm very very fortunate I'm very blessed
I want to thank everybody who sent me
any type of message any words of
encouragement you know um it was
heartfelt and I was very much
appreciated
um I'm gonna take this as a lesson
learned and for us that's why I was
still my health as well if I'm a little
less beefy now I lost about 10 to 15
pounds of muscle during the process and
I do have some residual residual effects
still get a little tired a lot but um
I'm doing better I'm doing better each
day as a step towards feeling better
I've been cleared for the gym you know
they really encouraged that and I'm
following up on my Specialists and just
making sure I'll take care any residual
things and things that nature but I
wouldn't I want to send the realm of the
Lord's you know the love because
um again for my brothers that always
checked on me everybody it was truly
over women thank you because um I
definitely you guys helped me pull it
through they were like God we need you
we can't we can't have a world without
you kind of thing so thanks everybody
for that so yeah we we lean beef right
now we lean beef we coming back you know
what I'm saying but other than that um
yeah as far as um the time for Pax West
I want to shout my brothers for holding
me down you know I would do the half
days and I would say hey that's it for
me I'm at my limit like around lunch
time we got you doing interviews doing
things you know what I'm saying so yeah
yeah I held it and also last week shout
out to cake shout out to King David hold
on let me find out I'm good now like
this man do a professional hosting shout
out to Super producer addict saving this
show look at you saving the show
switching over to a little steam yard
audible all right all right so I'm
holding it I was so proud of you because
I was nervous at first oh let's see how
it is only when you had the technical
difficult I wasn't nervous that y'all
couldn't do it I was just nervous when
the technical difficult so then Super
producer addicts like that now we got
this boom boom boom We gonna figure out
the hits and did I I like objective king
for a little bit oh he objective today
especially when they were supposed to
get Flames yeah yeah I was like oh look
at the balance
yeah when when Zoom because it was zoom
zoom was the issue when Zoom crashed the
second time after I reloaded I was like
I'm not even trying this I was like I
went straight to stream yards oh boy my
boy super audible uh but this show shout
out for the show was I was getting my
medication I had just got released for
the hospital that day so I'm driving
listen to y'all I'm like let's see
what's good it was good it saw breaking
it down yeah y'all was lit yeah I was
lit yeah you got the professor kid
glasses or I was like that that was out
of this yeah I gotta go away I'll take
some more weeks off I was like I like
this conservative
he like now I get to go in I had to
switch my um my political stance
now real talk I'm super proud of y'all
like that y'all know I'm just a little
bit over the top with just you know
trying to put my hand and everything and
just to see things were as smooth as
butter with y'all I was super fun I was
like I was doing shout out to the round
for showing the love so we got that yeah
other than me other than that I'm sorry
I got that I was gonna say we gotta like
address uh I know a lot of people like
the way the podcast looked last week the
the problem is is like a absurd about
people people messaging me saying you
know I think you could do it this way
the way our podcasters ran we'd have to
literally redo everything to go to
stream yards like it's it's not an
option unfortunately it would be a nice
option because stream yards has a lot of
tools that you know Zoom just doesn't
have but it's just not on the table
right and then there's a variety of
things we would lose some things
currently like what we do that we just
can't replicate on stream yards that's
kind of vital to the show so we're still
in talks if things improve we still
would think about doing it because
there's still a lot of benefits to the
to the other setup as well and obviously
the video was uh quality was that that's
the only thing I cared about that video
was on point right I would drop
everything just for that
so yeah we still searching we're always
going to start to improve other than
that again shout out to uh Maddie plays
shout out to finding Duke talking about
Starfield shout out the last words
Ashanti Barnes talk about Travis talking
about Starfield which is funny on the
destiny show we talk about that and then
for me um it's obviously it's been a ton
of Starfield um
I want to shout out the raw Galley
though man so one soft gave me the word
on the trip bro I don't know if it's
that that rdna3 but AMD and that's the
one Rising extreme trip is outside we
have to give AMD Day flowers bro that
joint I'm weren't running uh 720 fsr2
with RIS on I'm getting over 30 High 40s
in new Atlantis I'm getting over 60
frames in any indoor space combat in you
know environment bro I I know the
illnesses wave I'm telling you whatever
that AMD proprietary Tech they got going
on shout out to them that rock is out
here that is a fully functional little
key better than certain platforms
version of Starfield and it is super
impressive if you haven't got done it
update your drivers update your um AMD
Radeon uh app first uh then go to I go
to my Asus app update those drivers then
go to and go to the Windows store
Library update that and you'll see the
AMD icon pop up and yeah they out here
they doing the lowest work so I have the
AMD on that that little handheld they
doing their thing that is super
impressive and you know it's Windows
play anyway Game Pass so you go back and
forth so yeah salute to that that was
really really cool but uh yeah that's
for me and then as far as me on my pack
standout game shop shut this off holding
me down we did our little one two of
Dungeons and fintenburg I want to give
them a shout you know I wish they had a
jump button but
um no it was it was at the Xbox game
showcase
um it was really really cool um studio
and I believe covergames is the
publisher and they uh yeah they would
show that the Xbox game crashed the girl
with the sword on her back cell shaded
and they got some really cool puzzles
some of them really stuffed the combat
is actually not that bad they're still
early in development I think but um it
was really cool and um shout out to for
the kitten too turnbass Dungeons and
Dragons kind of I'm very passionate both
articles are upper Lords of gaming.net
go check them out we did some nice
coverage and like you said Tekken 8 was
outside so I didn't say my game well my
fault are you you're doing your turn I
messed up yeah okay what's your game
what was your game with Pax West sir
the boxing game oh yeah you remember the
name of the Box Big Boy boxes Big Boy
boxing
it is what I thought the team was going
to do for Super Punch Out like for the
for the next punch out
this game is crazy like it is the best
take of the best
I I don't know Nintendo need to buy them
or or need to just say you know what
listen man we can see y'all have done a
better punch out than we could ever do
or this updated Punch Out could be out
for but it's coming to the switch
it's that game and it's called a ton
blast that that's another one that I
like that look like Wario's world uh
from um the old uh what was that um that
3D device that they came up oh yeah yeah
Virtual Boy Virtual Boy it reminds me of
that Wario uh that came with that game
um but this boxing game the animation is
cuphead level animations for the bosses
that you fight yes 24 of them inside the
game and each one is unique in how
you're approaching and what's going on
it's stuff happening in the foreground
background and in front of you
um it is it's
it's to to explain it it's very hard to
get that level of Animation in a boxing
game they can give you so much
characterization they was going for a
Looney Tunes uh what did he say uh solve
Looney Tunes
um
somebody else well cuphead right or
something yeah he was going for that
game and it's insane so if you go go to
my Twitter all the interviews is up
there uh I'll put up a ton there to see
how it works uh a lot of times you're
gonna see when we cover shows we're
going to release that footage directly
on our um socials and on the iron Lords
uh social uh media pages so you can see
all the interviews there uh you know
these channels we're going to keep this
stupid game absolutely and also shout
out to some footage we couldn't capture
but shout out to me an addict during our
media hour run Sega Atlas was outside
um we played um the man who erased his
name the um to beat him up we're
carrying you shout out to all oh yeah
yeah yeah shout out to my mom what was
they playing on they would play it on
Xbox no no I don't wait wait the man who
played his name that was on PlayStation
on PC was it PC no I forgot what was
that I don't use it like a PlayStation
controller but I wasn't I wasn't sure in
the hardware attic because we played
that very quickly that we moved on I
think it was crazy yeah it may have been
PC but okay so so that was that beat em
up style you know what I'm saying carry
you your voice Vibe you know it's gonna
be young eventually with the American
joint but to me an addict I think would
agree the standout was Persona tactics
that was amazing now that was on Xbox
Hardware with a custom Xbox controller I
wanted that controller to you man
there's a I didn't look at that I was
like how you take this thing off
it's like how you take this thing they
let us ride yeah they let us Rock Sega
Outlets with outside they rarely go to
events and to see them in full force
with those games was really impressive
so shout out to them we was trying to
get the cover but they they was like
yeah we ain't letting nobody they're not
ready to Showcase that was like some
media exclusive type energy as far as
showcasing but yeah they they came out
there so anyway that's what I gotta saw
everyone get the super chats
um just the scrub or uh actually you
know before we go to the Super chats I
have um so I got a couple of DMs like
earlier before actually right during
while we were packs and I I completely
forgot to answer them so I'm going to
answer them quickly here so the first
one is from Loof uh let me see loofad
but
um uh they have for us and for our
community two codes to give away for
Dolby Atmos on Xbox for two years a
piece oh so I will be dropping these
codes uh throughout the show before oh
yeah I forgot about uh solve someone
wants to get some stuff away on Twitter
oh okay so we'll do that also I guess no
no that it's what it's saying that's
what it is
oops oops Yeah we were traveling when he
sent it and I just completely forgot
yeah so we're gonna do it we're gonna
just throw them in our chat
um
before I leave I'll drop both of them
let me get the redeem thing up let me
yeah I'll have that okay and then also I
got a DM from
Benjamin amaroo right because he he just
wanted to clarify something I guess he
had one of the questions for our during
our star field um sort of uh review
discussion and what he wanted to know
really was the chances that the chances
of encountering a black hole right and I
don't I don't have the answer for that I
don't know I don't think there's a black
hole in the game I think I think one of
us would have came across yeah I've
heard anybody talk about that and then
also let me see the how bad are the
zones and we talked about that about the
the the invisible walls the invisible
walls I haven't came across one Alana
Pierce was able to fly to to Pluto so
again like I think he's referring to in
the in on planets
they're there they are there but are you
looking for them or are you just playing
like if you're just playing you're not
gonna hit that wall if you're just
playing if you're looking for it because
there's no interactions anywhere near
that wall for the most part now
obviously you might spawn all like close
to one but I haven't you know I can't
speak every scenario that happens in
Starfield but what I can tell you is
I've never personally hit one yeah and
then uh what was it chances of
encountering uh life forms not of this
world well when you go to certain plants
you're going to see the the all the time
yeah you're going to have you know not
real animals on there so yeah I came
across little blue people that shot like
like lightning stuff at me yeah so it's
uh you're gonna find some stuff you
definitely find some stuff so that is
that so I will be dropping those codes
in the chat in a little bit cool so let
me described uh let me do these super
chats okay
describe okie dokie we got Robert
kellett ten dollars in the chat blessed
day Lords health is wealth both sides of
it seeing it there if it's finally and
just finished my second day at the gym
feels so much better take care of
yourselves and earn that beef
shout out to you yes yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
you ain't like that ain't nobody out
here earning no beef
very very crazy
oh you don't want the beef now now you
ain't earning no beef
well the Emojis actually meat they're in
that meat
you're unlimited time
we got Dragonheart Yobe member for 26
months Lord gold Lords are back welcome
back on the up and up Cognito we always
got you bro Lords keep up the good work
we are extremely proud of you all and
you're the wave you are The Vibes and be
legendary thank you man appreciate it
appreciate you
we got Cedric H remember for 38 months
Lord still but thank you for the crust
in the chapter Cedric H appreciate you
brother then we got Pat F member for one
month welcome welcome Lord bronze good
morning to all and blessed day to the
Lords and the realm excited for today's
show
then we got the homie Gerald Mack member
for 34 months Lord silver Xbox is
proving they don't need Sony to achieve
Mass success that has to that has to
scare them big name Sony bigger game
Xbox slash Microsoft all hail the ILP
they never needed him
messy then we got zip Davis five dollars
to the chat if it's the truth we got zip
with the drip zip
it is
so we got zip Dave it's five dollars if
it's star Pro is finally here I'm so
excited I spilled my truffle butter all
over the place
can't give me the music dude
homemade truffle butter he zipped with
the drip
he earned it now
so excited with his homemade truffle
butter
here's the thing do you want to do
something because it's gonna be funny or
do you want this man Keen talking you
out of doing something hold on I'm gonna
show you with zip
anyway good
there we go hustle and motivate five
dollar Super Chat happy 24th anniversary
to the Dreamcast just bought my second
one on Friday shout out to you shout out
to him shout out to Peter moore99 99 he
put the post up yesterday classic
Dreamcast pictures he has some like some
like uh uh Dreamcast promotional truck
kind of thing and he I guess there was a
concert with Limp Biscuit that they did
that he had the old phone man this is
what he wants you to look like
hey sit with the judge don't you dance
it got to get clear it got to do what
you did man
[Music]
[Laughter]
we good with that
I see one and CVS one are cops great
interview with Peter Moore y'all though
absolutely yeah look forward part two
coming part two coming it's soon too
yeah
then we got Randy G five dollars if we
chat good afternoon Lord It's good to
see y'all back on today just wanted to
say I have never seen a game received so
much hate from everywhere like Starfield
does yes
let's play with each other's joysters
it's five dollar Super Chat I adore you
too Sam I don't know when I said
anything to that
I want to adore every interview oh man
inflection is solved when he was at Pax
West did you have anyone ever knocked at
the door and not be there no yo you know
what was funny
it was I you know you put you put the do
not disturb sign on the door right
because I'm on it a couple of days don't
be coming into my room and but I would
hear if I thought it was a win but I
wouldn't I would kind of hear somebody
trying to turn them up
and that's the thing that's a thing
listen okay so it's a thing right and in
this whole traffic and human traffic and
stuff the wifey the whole time I'm away
she's sending me all this be careful the
hotel rooms watch out for the double
mirrors send me all these videos you
know Tick-Tock conspiracy at my room it
was another door to another room yeah I
I try to open it okay see okay so you
try to open it what if they would arrest
you from inside and put the heat on your
face right so that's fine then I would
have continued with the phrase why
didn't you tell me there's a door
connecting my room to another door like
I thought this this went to like a
closet or something like no that's a
whole nother room I find that to be
absolutely dangerous but so the thing
Solomon's talking about I heard it too I
thought I was bugging if it sounded like
somebody trying to Knob yeah jiggling
the door I'm like jiggling baby I'm like
it's the wrong place cause I'm gonna put
the GoPro on and we just we're gonna
make some money over there
[Laughter]
then we have project Aries five dollars
to pretend I'm happy Everyone likes
Starfield I'm not feeling it personally
CF Stars has warned me for the moment to
look to the Lords and around
and we got Dr Strange Love five dollar
Super Chat I know I know joystick is
your Mansa but I'm in the mood for
something Caliente oh you got somebody
new how about you pull out that chorizo
and let me take a bite whoa
[Music]
did say something in the um the
Starfield he's probably in the chat he
did say so uh he commented on the
Starfield oh the video oh that's what's
up yeah I'll see you this Sunday yeah
regular cows yeah I don't know if that's
it yeah
wow all right moving on
never ceases I ain't see any coverage of
Nintendo live I saw pictures of Sonic
but no pictures with Mario shaking my
head yeah we were not privy to that uh
your peoples your peoples don't provide
access
how about Nintendo allow other creators
to get access it's a very bro we try and
they remember that we went to apply it
was like yeah this is not available
anymore and I'm like damn they wall off
their situation you can't get in there
and then walking past I had one dude
because I was recording one of the
Pokemon game yeah and one dude ran from
across the room that you know the
Nintendo dudes ran across from across
you can't be recording I said why not
you need to stop that I was like what
for
yeah shout out to um N64 Josh who pulled
up yeah and the homies and they they
told us how they got a chance to play
what is it wonder and there was some
contests it seemed really fun wish I was
allowed to go but uh which we were
allowed to go yeah so talk to your
peoples
and you ain't saying nothing about the
topic though because who topic is a
Nintendo top yeah you switch to the
narratives I see what you do make
excuses trying to get this to be a
Nintendo show that's what your whole
thing is I know what you're doing
yeah
there we have four IQ no more no less
with the five euro Super Chat the
barbell blasting beefy bicep buff boy is
back I love the alliterations
yeah thank you Lord for the great
Starfield coverage salute lean beef
right now once again shout out to
Bethesda for you know letting us do that
because that's the that's the first time
we've ever been able to eat like as a
group as a podcast cast cover again
facts and it's basically a shout out to
Nick from the lordsgaming.net boy held
it down so basically five give y'all
five reviews in one so to speak from
five different perspectives
that was a a pain to edit I'm
unprecedented since the days of like
game pro facts shout out to Super
produce addict
then we have let's play with each
other's joysticks five dollars clapping
back I don't know who this Doctor
Strange Love is but you better back down
oh we out here having a a lover's
quarrel
[Music]
back to you
uh years ago now but he wrote that song
Tejeda Jaffe oh shout out to Jeffy to
Haida ps31 alumni 31. Clark Junior High
School
writer on that side oh God yes
fortunately passed away yesterday that
was the home we went to school with him
yes yes yes no doubt then we have uh but
yeah oh that song yeah
the song is mine
day one member for five months Lord
bronze glad to see you doing well [__]
just finished the free star faction
Quest Starfield does an easy game of the
year nominee great to see The Return of
the Lord thank you thank you good to be
back with everybody then we have project
Aries two dollar Super Chat Beyond beefy
[__] hashtag Health as well facts facts
yeah baby we on it slowly but surely
then we have jfx 88 five dollars Super
Chat I remember we used to call the PS3
the George Foreman grill yes I have that
foreman girl right in my living room has
the smoke session PS5 officially taking
that title
smoking ps5s evil yes yes yes
now we have pixel bit G member for 44
months Lord bronze good to see all four
horsemen on Deck today be welcome don't
get over encumbered yeah facts facts
I'll be taking it real easy get my rest
get my sleeve down pushing myself too
crazy
and we have for the legend two dollars
which have PlayStation has the worst
Fanboys ever seriously I mean Fanboys
and families did you did you see Jeffy
what happened with Jack yo yes shout out
to Jeffrey hold on I got a shout out
shout out to Jaffe cause he played oh
boy that came in there trying it with it
you see certain dudes with they they
hate narrative on searches
he's the beginning of the game yo Jaffe
literally made up how to be getting your
Starfield is it was like yeah so what
about that part yeah because this thing
he's like yeah that none of that exists
yo caught a body yeah caught a body
about a week ago
but that that's a good week ago yeah
we're taking time out of your day to
call into a live show
that's crazy
right
in the beginning you know it's really
boring because what's happened if you
look at it it's quite a mass effect
a lot of these dudes that's the scenario
he presented because he was like yeah
when your boss tells you you gotta body
this person and you don't find that
interesting it's a nah man you know he
said he said he said
you have the choice
that was cold that was cool old song you
gotta catch up to these stupid chats bro
Lord
we have uh the homie queasanti ten
dollars in the chat so look to the
Lord's on this fine Sunday just taking a
moment to show my support and just say
hello uh with how happy I am to see Lord
Cog healthy and back in the chair
continued Health Brothers
always you okay um I gotta uh do a zoom
with you in a minute don't think I
forgot we just doing all this pack stuff
no doubt okay the homie he said we have
Nintendo the otaku five dollars you
already know we exclusive over here I'm
gonna have to see if I can hook y'all up
with the Friend Code that invite to the
next one yeah Miyamoto kept us out it
ain't that about us speak the boss
please yeah and we got Mandingo Mick
Dickens five dollar Super Chat did Saab
say something about turning knobs did I
what are you talking about
after you today you ain't getting out of
here
I just love Richard richarding space in
my yeah uh um ship wow wow wow wow wow
somebody said we have an iron Lord pause
casting yeah
we have Doctor Strange Love Again five
dollar Super Chat joystick do I sense
fear in your voice
ah worried that Sam is going to give me
all his chorizo
that skirt is going to happen wow
there'll be no chorizo distribution here
today or any other day you need to give
it up
[Music]
there we have moving on
two dollar Super Chat David Jaffe doing
the Lord's work yes that was that was
hilarious on Japanese stuff then we got
here to the Macho Man uh ten dollars in
the chat all hail the incredible Lord
General King I received the new orders
the portal will face the same famous
psvr too did Sir the blue team is
putting uh cases on all of Sony
employees over star for you oh my Lord
be good we good yes no doubt it's that
time of the month y'all Lords of
gaming.net time and uh yeah it's that
time we celebrate the great Riders the
great talent we have shout out to the
entire team always a competitive
situation every month it's just it's an
electrical we're super proud of what
we're doing very blessed but we got to
celebrate one particular scribe who went
Above and Beyond in the month of August
really really killing it on an absolute
tier with all things Evo in the fighting
game community
uh Destiny 2 Season the witch R and R
with the Lords our latest social media
Community manager for lordigaman.net
proudly present the latest winner of the
Disney log net scribe of the month to my
fam Lord Thai Channel now tight wasn't
able to make it but uh what we're gonna
do is uh actually have our recording so
give me a second here
[Applause]
good evening to everyone in the realm
this is Thai Tano AKA dragon slayer
Telos your scribe of the month
um as always I'm very grateful for
accepting this reward I apologize for
the strange sounds in the background
slash no video only audio I was sick for
the past few days so I forgot to do a
proper
um video but anyways
um as always Lords of gaming.net is a
wonderful place to be there are
wonderful writers and editors all around
I very much love and appreciate my time
here learning and growing uh in the
games industry
so make sure to check out our content
check out r r with the Lords with me
king and addict uh we have big things
hooking up so just stay tuned the realm
thank you so much take care of
yourselves and have a great day
extreme yeah you know because we
couldn't do uh Ty couldn't do video this
particular but uh again the love is
there so uh yeah well Ty will be reached
out and uh we definitely take care of of
our our friend and all done sir okay
thank you thank you
thank you I appreciate it again Ty
scribe of the month and shout out to
Teespring once again because uh
Lord C Unit the most patient man in the
world wow
July describe of the month is just in
the wind yeah July we was going to do
Grace isn't gonna be here today okay
you're not muted
um
I love it that was dope that was dope
and uh secondary locked everywhere again
going from my brother uh dizzy where we
talk about the nurtures of Talent
editorial team and um look do you want
to give proper credit to our unsung
heroes behind the scene this editor not
only one of the most soothing voices of
of reason you know but is the epitome of
reliability and what happened with damn
writer himself you know he uh really
extremely talented what I really
appreciate is the convention coverage
the organization the management of the
War Room gcx Gamescom packs West and
then um also a Stellar review I had a
ton of great reviews I believe scores
above Atlas Fallen
um Immortals of AVM and recently onward
core you know and uh truly a jack of all
trades so we try we proudly present the
winner the latest Lil dizzy long net
editor of the month to the chief the
Editor in Chief my brother my man Laura
AKA my mood gafar how we doing
how's it going guys
right now let's go yes yeah you can tell
guys is the real stuff you know yeah I
could tell it's official because I got a
Muslim Center uh next round and I can
see I can see that I was like this this
is authentic yeah
I told you we are well funded yeah yeah
exactly leave us alone leave us a little
we outside with it don't have about move
come through
edited cheap okay brother
yeah I just want to say thank you for
you guys thanks for everything and thank
you for keeping me very busy for the
past couple of months my God I haven't
done this many reviews in for the site
ever bro I think after the next big XBox
exclusive I'm gonna take a little break
for it yes
yeah yeah be on the lookout for tomorrow
we got special content realm yeah I'm
very excited you know I'm the NBA boy
appreciate everything you guys and if
you guys want to join log mats apply to
the website we'll help you get your
tracks into this industry and yeah it's
a great team a great team love you
brother you are the foundation you're
the rock you Rose to the occasion took
this thing the leadership Thing by the
mantle by the horns and we haven't
looked back since and again I it's also
your soothing and approachable style to
new talent and it's really cool and just
the way you keep things going obviously
you know I've been through a lot and to
see the site not miss a beat during that
time when I haven't been able to
participate I want to personally thank
you brother because without you you're
the thing that keeps the ship on course
so love you brother salute you
love you guys too thank you so much
Falcon have a great show guys all right
you already know my brother bro Lord way
here in the chat we good to go anything
else um we no patreon questions no poll
last week anything else
a couple of a couple of them okay
we have Necromancer sale five dollars
for chat did the IOP only fans leak into
the stream
please don't go crossing the streams
lore
there we have let's play with each
other's joysticks five dollars in the
chat there's nothing to fear me and Sam
have an unbreakable Bond and he knows
I'm the only I'm the only dip for his
child what the only dip for the who was
his shorties I can't even say oh man
yeah they look like Puerto Rico repeat
that I didn't oh besides his lovely wife
of course
you know he can't he don't have a kid
have been married like whatever for my
flag down that's crazy what else he got
then we got uh rap Legend Freddy Fox
5 super chat political King is whack
though ever want to see that again
political
six million players and two men really
concurrent her into certain group's
feelings that's right I wish I could
hold the line oh man
like I'm taking four days I saw the show
red like clockwork diffusers
you didn't have to do that you could
have just been you could have just been
messy King yeah and I would have tried
to Wrangle it together if you was too
busy laughing
I knew I wouldn't have I'd encourage the
foolishness and this is what I told the
people I said listen man hug ain't gonna
be here and you know I got to do button
down
and continue to push me to do more
foolishness
what else we got some we got that's that
they were caught up with the with the
only fan section
shout out to the dirty section of
YouTube sympathy drip anyway um
this game going on right now launching
and things happening
no no after the first time oh uh real
quick too yeah yeah you know we have a
lot of content on our patreon you know
we we do a really bad job promoting that
thing we need to do a lot better uh so
you know r r has been moved over there I
do make that public because I do want to
give you guys a taste of what type of
coverage you're going to get over there
but there's reactions you know I think
King says they're going to do more stuff
in terms of like uh you know reviewing
movies and stuff I I don't you know King
want to remark on that we do reactions
to game stuff you can ask questions uh
to every one of the shows I have put r r
back on there uh so I I think I think
you guys would really enjoy the type of
quality that we do provide to uh the
patreon members so I'll put put the
patreon and the the leak in the chat and
you know go over there and give it a
little a little swing man there's a lot
of content already over there especially
if you add anime lovers and you know
King King has almost reacted to like two
seasons of Attack on Titan over there
already so showing me up to the patreon
you already know and then y'all could
start telling me what movies y'all want
me to go see like you know the nun two
and a whole bunch of other scary movies
or y'all can send me to go see some
foreign film that I got to read the
bottom of the screen do something
push me to the movies no doubt so solve
you are up Starfield in the news what's
going on
yeah apparently that little game from
Todd Howard's team is uh has found some
measure of success
um it came out and it has been doing
pretty damn well despite all of the
discourse around it which is undulating
should I say up and down Hills and
Valleys in terms of how people feel
about the game but in general
I think the game is it
is faring very well now let's look at
some of the numbers so uh first off in
terms of sales right this game that is
available in Game Pass uh Market
Microsoft did the brilliant thing of
selling Early Access through Game Pass
and selling it for what like 35 or 40
dollars
and that caused the uh the Early Access
concurrent players to reach one million
at least one million and that was and
that that number was probably surpassed
meaning that one million at least one
million people in Early Access paid for
that game up front
um
Tom Anderson this is the past two
billion yeah so now it's it's surpassed
that right
um then on day one when when it was
available to everyone they hit something
like in the realm of six million players
overall and at one point having again
like we said over one million very fast
too very very fast to become essentially
bethesda's best launch uh ever in terms
of uh and success in terms of their game
so uh this is a game that people have
been anticipating right because they
love it because they want to hate on it
whatever the case may be this game is a
game that everyone has been waiting for
for a very long time and it's it's
having its moment in the Sun and I don't
think any game
any game that that is kind of of this
stature and this nature is going to have
a lot of discourse around it positive
negative you know and it becoming a game
that at one point right before Bethesda
and and xenomax became a part of
Microsoft before it became a part of of
that and became exclusive to Xbox
um a game that was supposed to be like a
third party game right right one would
assume would be a third party game and
now it's it's become part of that
discourse as well as we said when we
talked about the whole David Jaffe thing
so uh the game is the game is doing very
very well overall and yeah again this
course around it when it comes to the
reviews and what people like about it I
don't like about it
um I think it's kind of it's funny like
the numbers are the numbers are the
numbers right and you can be angry about
a number unfairly on you know whatever
bringing down an overall aggregate down
or whatever the case may be but at the
end of the day these type of games
specifically these Bethesda the games
have very long tails
they continue to improve over time and
the idea of the game is not to blast
through it necessarily in you know in a
couple of days it is to it these games
are lifer games right it's for you to
kind of get lost in that world and keep
finding out its secrets and there's
plenty of stuff that people who have
already played a hundred hours of this
game probably have not found because
that is the nature of this type of game
so
um the discourse around it doesn't
surprise me and it's going to continue
to undulate but you know up and down so
um I'm excited to keep playing it again
I I was one of those guys that I had I
have almost 80 hours in the game right
with the Early Access I have done near
nothing of that story I went in and said
okay I'm gonna just mess around I'm
gonna go kill space pirates I'm gonna go
land on planets and see what's there
that's what I did
um and I had a great time doing it and
again the game is there for you to do
what you want to do and create your own
story so I'm glad that it's I'm glad
that it's it's having success I'm glad
that the narrative around it say what
you will about how you feel about the
game or whatever nitpicking certain
things it is a Bethesda ass Bethesda
games it is that game
um if you've played those games before
you kind of know what to expect here
it's just in a different universe and
and it's and it's larger it's faster
um but end of the day it is it is that
game and the discourse will continue
around it and uh
did so much discourse around this game
is so uh magnificent oh you know the
moment the moment they're like only on
Xbox and the Xbox ecosystem and this is
this is this is gonna happen
why isn't bold this game getting the
same uh vitriol it's uh I think oh
[Laughter]
I think the reason it's getting hit is
because it's getting hit from multiple
angles I think there's people
I think there's people that didn't that
didn't like the you know the
consolidation that Microsoft's doing so
I feel like this is their way of you
know combating that I think there's
people that like Baldur's Gate and
they're scared that Starfall might take
it for game of the year so that
community's rolling up I think some of
the Nintendo fans they ain't feeling
uncomfortable with the Baldur's Gate and
Starfield is is breathing down tears of
the Kingdom but my point is is like
there was one point where tears of the
kingdom was kind of the de facto like to
see nothing else you out first of course
your drip look nice and then when you
get a chance to see everybody else drip
your drip this really didn't look all
that nice that DLC
I think what you're seeing is just a
culmination of of a PlayStation fans
Baldur's Gate fans and this is the the
the the later end of the spectrum like
the the people that probably need
therapy like this is them people you
know coming out uh you know because it's
just like if you think about like the
logicity of the matter like this this
means nothing it's like who cares what
one's Game of the Year
where I draw the where I draw the line
is I don't like when people use
the Metacritic system for their own
benefit right I feel like I feel like
what do we say these days all Metacritic
it's it's Metacritic it's it's like how
I feel like when we talk about Nintendo
where people are like oh it's a Nintendo
you should just expect it it's like no I
expect Nintendo to get for the 23rd 23rd
century
and I
expect also
us as a community
that's what I'm saying they so far
behind I need them ahead you need oh you
need to be two sets okay okay yeah I
need the Manhattan because they so far
behind yeah and then I'm sitting here
looking at like metacrit it's like you
know it's easy just to say well
Metacritic has a flawed system
I'm done with that flawed system because
if we don't speak up it's never going to
get fixed why has it been years and
years of Metacritic having five out of
five scoring system and they haven't
fixed that it's like okay so why is it
because the PlayStation news is eating
I'ma tell you this now and that critic
is about to change in a second you go
get your wish and I'm just sitting here
like
okay regardless how these people are
manipulating matter because I do I think
you know I made a video a man comes up
with a 76 man
yeah so yeah our RPS is high yeah
we messing up RPS you you can go look at
uh after the show you can look at the
the video I made where you know I'll go
over all the the very very low and I'm
not even talking sevens talking six is
below there was one that only had eight
reviews on Metacritic wow and Starfield
was by far the worst
they there was one that reviewed uh what
was the game it reviewed Saint Rose is
an eight
chains yes
I I just look if these people generally
thought this game was that bad
you know to give it a six or a five out
of ten okay rock it with that opinion
but if they're using
console war stuff on Twitter and they're
trying to generate traffic that ad that
that results in Revenue if that is their
goal and I and I do I think it's the
latter I think people are are
deliberately manipulating the system to
get traffic on there and it's not just
an Xbox problem it's an industry problem
PlayStation that's the reason it has so
many PlayStation games get 89 that don't
hit in the 90s that's the reason it
doesn't seem to affect Nintendo like at
all like I I don't I don't know what
that's about but it's just like because
Nintendo people don't got internet I'm
sorry
form Starfield is not a four out of ten
you know there's a difference between
being objective and and
there's a strict line where people put
that line in the dirt and they're like
if you go above this you're you're just
trying you're just trying to you know
Captivate an audience to your website
yeah and I'm sitting here looking at
things and you know one only reviewed
six games like I said one gave uh you
know Saint Rose and eight out of ten and
when you're looking at the one that gave
it uh eight out of ten almost every game
they have reviewed because uh me and
smooth are looking at it when we did
Planet Xbox yesterday
all of them were above
above uh star field almost every single
one of them I think I think they
reviewed like crash team racing or
something and that got like a five but
besides that like the last two years
have been eight in a bus but you needed
to tell me that all of a sudden racing
is great like costume racing is not a
five either like that I don't know if it
was crash team it was one of those
racing games but it's just like you mean
to tell me all of a sudden
now they score in sixes and fives it
just it doesn't make sense because if
you look at it the higher end of the
spectrum they've gave a lot of games
positive reviews like way more games
than negatives now when we talk about
the four out of ten that individual just
you know seems like it's one of those
scenarios where you they're just very
hard on games and you get to the point
where you look at the actual amount of
negative reviews of games that that
individual done I'm just saying like do
you even like games hmm like oh the
majority of games five out of ten six
out of ten five out of ten four out of
ten do you like games
well I gotta say quick Interruption on
that is that me why you got Lord to give
him down that is doing so many reviews
per year we can't seem to get automatic
critic for some reason Metacritic which
is which is quite interesting so again I
just find it interesting that you're
telling me addicts that um you know
people that with only four or what is it
eight reviews you said there's some
sites eight reviews yeah eight reviews
and they gave the Stray a 10 out of 10.
yeah me right we gotta log that out here
doing the Lord's work for that reason
we've been trying to apply y'all so I
don't know I don't know what that is
going over there but Metacritic if you
are listening we got a lot of people
that listen to the show please holler at
us you saw about moogafar or um
editor-in-chief on here you can reach
out to myself Lord Cognito at lord.c at
Lords gaming.net and holler because we'd
like some answers as to why this process
is not happening we were told actually
we were I'm putting business out let's
go we were told we didn't have enough
reviews
oh yeah we were told about a year ago
we've been trying to reapply so I just
find it interesting that what is it what
is it hot for the nightsight.com
because we out here really doing
journalism media we go on events we're
getting exclusive what's up Metacritic
don't love you open Credit you're not
voting in favor of the favorite platform
though oh okay okay you gotta be in
pocket I mean to be honest with you as
much as that we would normally like you
know joke around with King on a tape
like that that's what it looks like
because when you look at the games
they're reviewing they're they're
extremely reviewing PlayStation games
and a highlight like I said you know
they gave uh they gave God a war like a
nine or something out of ten minutes put
the Lords of game in the chat y'all put
free free log net
hit up better credit
to me
I think we're I've just gotten to the
point with Metacritic where it's like
we're either going to take this website
serious or not and it's like they're
clearly not fixing their own ship you
know I don't blame the content creators
the website owners for manipulating A
system that allows it to be manipulated
but if you are clearly seeing
that that it smells like
I can't say because I can't cuss
funky up there and you're so oh it's
cool it's cool it's it's like equivalent
to your your dog you know doing his
business in the house and you just Smell
You Just Let It Rock yeah you know it's
good you know I ain't gonna clean it
it's good you know what's crazy though
like we say that right but it's funny
you know the the opposite to Metacritic
is open critic right people like okay
that is the that is the platform that
feels like it's more
um on the level where that they're both
at an 87. and the game is at an 87 on
both Metacritic and and open critic
right so it's kind of any attempt to
manipulate the system at you know
overall it seems like it hasn't really
worked in this in this I'm saying this
let us in this
instance.com but we we let free log net
y'all come on my boy look at my total
130 reviews right now which is crazy
yeah man what's up not enough okay
somewhere enough because you got King
David over there yeah yeah yeah
that's just my biggest criticism with
the whole thing look if you generally
think the game's a six five seven out of
ten even IG and I don't agree with uh
you know Dan's review but it is what it
is I could objectively to a point see
okay you know maybe you just had the
worst playthrough ever had the most bugs
I have been told there's certain Builds
on PC that this game is Just crashing
like crazy
through it I don't know if they played
it on PC for that point and you know
people uh I told dudes they got to
update I said get that AMD get your age
and your PC game ain't lit get that AMD
get your driver's tight get that fs3b
you're running with the wrong drivers
people were bringing up okay attic you
know maybe the reason the PC version
isn't running is good because a lot of
people you know they have Nvidia or
however you want to pronounce their game
and you know a lot of uh you know they
did that partition with AMD you know
maybe that is you know maybe maybe
Bethesda pushed a lot more in optimizing
AMD and it resulted in a lot of the
other gpus not running the greatest when
it comes to Starfield and if that's the
case then that was the wrong decision
but because now you got some of these PC
reviewers that just aren't really having
a good time uh but it's just like I
played this on Windows and I don't know
I do have uh I have a a CPU that's amp I
don't have a GPU right now and you know
I have no issues like that I have a 30
60 TI and for the most part the game ran
good and I did it did crash once or
twice but I that was all so it's just
like I don't know like it's like I said
maybe they came across the worst patches
you possibly could come across and it's
just like but to me
what they're saying how many bugs is in
this game I'm just not experiencing
solution
I had a solution for those PC dudes
since it's playing everywhere they go by
as to shut up it is running good on us
too it's fun and delicious
that's that's all for me you know it's
not really a whole lot I have to say
besides that I just I think the industry
could do better like and you know I I'm
getting tired of like being attacked on
Twitter that's like you know why do you
care so much about a review score now I
care about the Integrity of of our one
of our Outlets to review games the
process yeah I don't care about the
score the score isn't relevant in this
matter it's it's the process that's
being abused that's the problem and it
feels like more people would rather make
a blind eye and say you know go to your
favorite YouTuber or something and it's
like no let's address the problem and
fix it
look for that King your thoughts on uh
star Fields launch success and Views if
you want to touch that told dudes
yo y'all didn't want this day to happen
because like please don't let King get a
w I told you what was gonna happen this
year it's been the best year
this has been the absolute best time of
my video game control life that I've had
like you guys has been y'all have to
play on X now and y'all can call it
Twitter all you like but
it's called
I thought we were supposed to crumble
when redfall hit ah but there's always
throw our whack games anyway Game of the
Year up your butt here it is wow
don't you love how he wants to always
like do the pause moments but when he
does the pause moment he's Gonna Let It
Rock he's gonna beat him he put a beat
on it I hate the pause very quickly but
I'm gonna let y'all know y'all do not
like this y'all try to fight it any type
of way I saw dudes before the game was
hidden it ain't gonna be good it ain't
gonna be good at all
and then they had to play it and now
those dudes is like well I was a little
bit wrong
six million people
six million Millions don't give numbers
y'all got them numbers now
yo they was calling for a line appears
to me yo that was wild
how dare she enjoyed
somebody they said they somebody
snitched was like Herman Holtz yeah
oh they was really mad like she's not
allowed to play stop feeling enjoy
herself that's where I said I feel like
some people on Twitter need therapy and
I really do like
but the best part about it it was like
we can't have this
we can't have them having fun
they started making up scenarios I've
been playing the games and I've been
hiding the bodies
you guys are so going crazy all right so
to this Metacritic crap this is what
y'all get this is a double edge blade
y'all said hey y'all was running around
with it oh it's great for y'all right
oh when y'all want to raid a game high
oh this game is it's Second To None it's
it's Christ in a box it's happening this
is it and now when it's our turn now
we're going we're going we're gonna
double down we're gonna break this down
we're gonna break this down you know
that blade swings both ways right y'all
do know Spiderman is sliding out the
door yeah unfortunately unfortunately
yeah
it's the part of the game I don't like
it cause you know but I'ma say this a
lot of Xbox dudes was gonna try to
honestly take her pictures of the MPCs
what retaliation with calm down it's
more uh retaliate now see you part of
the problem
I don't think the Xbox dudes is gonna go
to Metacritic and try to uh review bombs
oh Spiderman I'm I'm giving the Xbox
dudes a little bit more
it's it's
I I don't really see it I think because
we have more stuff to play
right I really think I think if you know
they always tell me Idle Hands is the
devil right so their hands is idle
looking on Twitter and they look I mean
looking on X and they looking on YouTube
and they seen everybody having fun they
say you know what I gotta review bomb
this
is true they said this game was whack
because the burning bodies like I had no
choice but to burn the bodies and this I
don't care about anybody eating my food
this I told y'all guys a long time ago
fire if y'all stop looking at Metacritic
if y'all stop giving energy to
Metacritic then Metacritic will stop to
exist but y'all keep running over there
oh when they review your game hi y'all
want to talk these numbers that's a good
point you can't tell the numbers when
it's in your favor and then when it's
not in your favor oh you see this
metacritical we gotta fix it we're
either gonna agree that it's important
or we're just not it's not important to
me at all it's never been important to
me I don't care what anybody eats
because it don't let me blank so
y'all guys keep running y'all giving
them the energy I wouldn't know what the
Metacritic score for the game is at all
I don't know until y'all tell me the
reason why is I don't give energy to
something I don't care about so
obviously young individuals care about a
Metacritic score obviously somebody
else's opinion means more than your very
own opinion
you got to stop giving other people
power to have control over you and they
having control of you so if this is what
happens you see a game rate of 70.
you could have been anticipated in that
game all year
but it's a 70 I don't know if I should
pull a trig on that because you know Tim
Tim up up north said I tip up north he
didn't like the way the donkey's legs
I don't know about this
grow some be better and stop worrying
about everybody else
go do what you want to do give your own
opinions and value your dollar more and
stop giving being quick to give away
your power Metacritic has no control
over a great game a great game is a
great game because of your experience
and you can't talking about experience
if you didn't play it and worried about
what review dude said about said that's
kind of boss you just you're taking away
the whole part of video games it's the
experience it's the journey do you know
how many whack games I love
and if I listen to Somebody talk about
how Crackdown was trash I would have
never had so much fun in Crackdown
you gotta stop this right so as far as
Metacritic having control over what's
being said and what's being done it's
you giving up your control well this is
because meta critic is not giving you a
rebate on something that you love oh
medical use wrong this was good here can
I get my 20 back they don't care
it's not gonna happen get right back to
what gaming is supposed to be
experiences that you talk to your friend
about hey yo try this I've played it as
dope oh it didn't rate good on
Metacritic I don't know I think this one
for fairness this is less about
metacriting but let the review stuff
later I hear what Alex told Mom but this
one was more about I guess the concert
is more about the IGN 7 is what I think
okay this okay
it's cool to look at magazines and say
to yourself oh I want I value their
opinion right
when somebody says something that you
feel is not true or something that you
don't believe the only reason why he got
a bunch of steam with it is be and
people start doing their investigative
journalism or why didn't they give it to
so and so
stop giving them views if you don't like
the shenanigans that what happened if
Dan did this stop looking at Dan
articles
if you're enough of y'all do with that
in Mass
he'll stop his BS
because it's all about clicks and views
right so if he does this oh I can do
this I'm my fan base is going to grow
this way he's going to have the
PlayStation dude support him and I have
the Xbox dudes go against it in this
article I put up will go this way it's
whatever I wouldn't know because I
didn't read it I wouldn't know because I
didn't care I'm not going to give Dan
that energy if you're going to give
somebody that energy you got to
understand at the end of the day
IGN is not the end-all be-all there's
other sites that you can go to but
there's a bigger site that you can go to
it's called yourself
and you can go and use your money
because I hate you and it's not 70
sending you 70 to go play Starfield you
earn to get it go get it and play it or
go check it out in Game Pass and if you
don't want to play something don't do it
because somebody else told you it was a
five do it because you just didn't have
any interest in it but don't let
somebody change your interest from
a 10 in your heart to a seven because
they reviewed it as a seven right don't
let nobody temper your expectations for
something be excited use your own
experiences and then go around and talk
about it share that that's a community
share that yeah I'll jump in um look
super proud of Bethesda team um they had
a lot of pressure on them to deliver on
this game yeah make no mistake and um
again it's not perfect it may not be for
everyone but for sci-fi fans core RPG
fans and me personally like he said I
absolutely love this game so um yeah I
mean 2 Milly what is it uh Early Access
paid 100 paid versions alone yeah over
one million on Xbox one million on Steam
before release
super impressive obviously we had over
like 340 000 consecutive people playing
it on Steam and from what I heard
internally from Microsoft
they have exceeded this thing has
exceeded their own kind of aggressive
yeah I was told at the higher end of it
yeah like they've exceeded their higher
end internal metrics that they thought
they were going to get so this has been
a monster then we're talking six million
on launch week the highest what does the
game launch ever right huge I guess for
me my curiosity will be I'm curious
about the Game Pass
um subscriber count and a new subscriber
count especially not at the um one
dollar thing is removed before Starfield
I think that'll be interesting
um to me the stat no one's talking about
is um when I was writing my notes for
for this at the time it was um number
four I checked today right now it is the
third most played game on Xbox and that
means it had to uh dethroned one of the
free to plays right so it's right now
fortnite number one monster
Call of Duty number two monster and
Starfield is the third and it's been
consistent most played actually this is
a single player obviously no um what you
call it multiplayer aspect in it right
game
ahead of all these other monsters and
that that's crazy ahead of Grand Theft
for Grand of Rainbow Six my Minecraft
Madden uh Apex Legends Roblox Rainbow
Six C that is insane
so this already and we got then I think
it's the most paid it's it's on
something like let's see top pay let's
see top paid right now let's go hit that
right quick number two
top paid people paid still for it Madden
only ahead of it and this is the thing
about this though oh yeah you know that
but think about this this is Madden on
the day of the football season just
started matter right so you know it's
going to be this is ridiculously
impressive numbers y'all you you can't
spin it you know no no negative way
that's why I said you gotta shout out
the team so that's what I want to say
remember kids Twitter is an echo chamber
remember kids there's a lot of people
who full-time job was to fight this game
they were doing the fear uncertainty
doubt there's the same old Bad actors
doing the same old thing logging in
every day to show screenshots and why
the game is is gonna be not successful
and No One's Gonna like it's gonna fall
off I saw it all and I'm sitting there
laughing I'm laughing because no matter
no amount of
self-imposed hate is gonna stop what the
realm of the people have said the people
have spoken so what that shows all that
don't matter that's that's you and this
10 loaf made up world real life people
went out and go get this game so that's
the real thing right there and as far as
reviews I kind of spoke about this all
that and nauseam already you know I'm
kind of in the same pocket as king No
One's Gonna tell me how my food tastes I
don't like look reviews are subjective
anyone's around have allowed the right
to say it's a six five seven whatever
that's their business right my thing is
go to the people one that you respect
two that like the games that you like
that are knowledgeable in the games that
you like right and three sometimes I
like when
you know we have a person on and we're
like yo I've never played it but that's
the game before right and you go okay
and this person gives it eight this
person gives a nine to me that holds a
lot of weight because I know that's that
their first time of experience with with
a game like that so yeah like all this
other stuff you know and my thing is
this look
on one hand I get it you know we
let's be real you know this is this is
the coronation moment you know what I'm
saying everybody wanted this stuff
you'll get that 90 something plus or
whatever whatever I get it this was the
one God how was first game people really
wanted to celebrating champion and this
kind of shot off that new era because
let's be honest in the Xbox One era it
was the realm of this yellow 65 minute
some games that went so I get it you
know my awesome other thing is as far as
from the review standpoint the only
thing I disagree personally for what Dan
did is he he should have stood on his
seven and walked away
the minute you start going back and
looking at well I gave this review that
now you're feeding into the questions
people have right you're fueling that
right and so so to me just stand on it
don't do any spaces don't do any of that
stuff because now it just does it in my
opinion you know look good and then the
other thing I do want to say is that I
don't care how big your outlet even at
lawrencegaming.net you saw my brother
Mahmoud came on
you you're not no review is absolved
from criticism either just because
you're a big Outlet does it mean you got
it couldn't have gotten it wrong either
right so and we've had games like that
back in the past that we looked at all
games of the generation but when how
they were scored at that time wasn't
necessarily thing so again again all I'm
saying I'm not saying that they are not
there's no checks and balances at IGN
but similar as us as a smaller Outlet
when my mood put something up he got to
go through checks and balances with
another editorial team to make sure to
look through you see what I'm saying so
that that's what I'm saying again I'm
not saying that doesn't go on over at
these other outlets but you can't
the only reason why I'm bringing this up
is because it was told to me in a spaces
there was some things said by him that
didn't
um didn't add up to the amount of
gameplay hours and stuff for people who
really played it and some people were
questioning and let's be real and it's
the last thing I'll say
Starfield is a type of game not even two
weeks at it it's like enough
if you really think about it if this is
a game you just blaze the storyline or
whatever whatever you still miss out on
so much of this game so this is a very
unique game anybody who played these but
that's that's not enough it really is
honestly probably about a month
yeah like the PlayStation fan base yo
you stupid so it's just like again these
are how traditional the Skyrims the
fallouts you know what I'm saying the
oblivions you're not gonna see you're
not you're only gonna see like a fourth
of the game and you're making a decision
on a fourth if and again I got look I
gotta support the whole team you know um
yeah that's why our review was in
progress because there's no way there's
no way it'll be the equivalent of like
the new Destiny thing came out and you
you didn't rate the raid you didn't do
the raid or you didn't do you know what
I'm saying like it's you still didn't do
the whole picture so that's just my
opinion on it but again last thing guys
stop attacking people just because they
disagree with you ain't no need to get
personal and all this you know we need
them fired you can you can disagree
bullying a person is not a goal wait a
second car you mean to tell me
I'm working at Sony yeah
nah man that's the opposition man
you can't be playing no listen I love
games but we can't play their games
it's against the law anyway
yeah I mean I think the funny thing is
it's just that like Gamespot gave it the
same the same seven
Michael Heim got none of that smoke and
I think part of it was that like you
said he I think he just that's my seven
I'm not engaging in any discourse
goodbye you know why they didn't care
nobody care about Game Spot it's not
games Game Spot number two you can't
like can't response number two like
nobody can but I don't really go to game
spot right it's true but they are number
two yeah number two what is number two
all right
so yeah that's that that's that okay so
let me get these super chats then I'm
gonna handle my business
all right
could you just give your thoughts or or
on the Internet
absolutely I definitely want to hear
your thoughts and we see uh hold on a
second uh we have Lucius Augustus
remember for 24 month Lord brand
Starfield is a top selling game on Steam
in the United States and globally and
number two in the U.S XBox stores top
paid games only behind Madden 24. yeah
people actually buying games
pray time Dragonheart yo me two dollars
Super Chat documentary about Starfield
Dev time yes please yes a documentary
about
Starfield from the very beginning that
would be awesome
then we got Nintendo Taco two dollars
which had nobody on Nintendo's side
worried about them
then we got uh Jada pissed six one seven
Jada pissed jda pissed I will call you
Jada pissed wow six one seven five
dollars large and vast I wish Saab would
say that about my chorizo what whoa
add
another one
it's great
and we have yeah let's put the question
to chat for the first Super Chat from
Jada pissed six months
then we got red and black dog remember
for one month Lord bronze it's like on
Steam you can see how many hours a
person has played on their on their
review of a game lets you know how much
to weigh their opinion oh that's good
let me holler at somebody Tim Dylan I
wish Cognito would be real with his
opinions and stop being political people
need to be held accountable I don't care
about what someone thinks about
something I love you do like you you're
allowing another man to steal your joy
because of review couldn't be me so I'm
sorry it's I'm never gonna be in my
feelings at that point so that's where
me and you are just not gonna lie love
you though but I just had to put that
out but this is the thing like
No Cap whatsoever if that game deserved
that level of smoke right you would see
you would hear it here but trust me like
the the question is that we people it
feels like people are playing different
games right right in some instances and
in other instances it's just the fact
that people have different opinions and
that's fine there's nothing wrong with
that but here's my problem when I when I
when I read comments like that it's like
oh what hair you saying the game is
rigged you know all these guys are
unfair why you seeking validation from
someone you claim is phony and rigged
you looking for the validation I don't
care about validating from someone that
I don't a respect or care about their
opinion that's the division care y'all
sitting there like please we want the 90
we want the not do not care if bro I
play Destiny I don't care what nobody
think you know what I'm saying like this
games that I'm I'm out here championing
midnight Suns did that game break
Metacritic you know what I'm saying like
God worries so much about the people
y'all claim right is phony and and
unfair and rigged and biased and stop
supporting them support them support the
real that's all anyway yeah
all right then we have base 23b can why
twenty dollars BG 3 or Zelda will win
game of the year this year and I haven't
played a game this gen yet that wowed me
like Red Dead 2 in terms of Graphics
attention to detail and immersion
listen you you want to be ignorant
that's the joke no no no no and that's
that right there there you go right
there there you go you're wrong that's
it
damn it
then we have booty remember 25 bus load
bronze enough respect to IOP the
original
the young staff here stop here
blood clots
that's so funny stop here it sounds like
Eartha Kitt stop here
hahaha
[Laughter]
yeah we got a lot of roughness five
pounds
a lot of roughness
all week too many folks too many folk
nitpicking and absolute great game in
Starfield the Xbox win we've been
waiting for since this is how we share
games
and that's the thing though I get it
like you know it's just some people just
like love to hate and love to like throw
you know just throw poo poo in your snow
but it's just like and we know this is
gonna happen we knew this was gonna
happen because it was either going to be
if the game is not good across the board
there was going to be that discourse and
if it's good or if it's if it's like it
is where it's like some people love it
some people it's not for them whatever
the case may be this is always going to
happen right so it's just the nitpicks
are gonna happen right uh listen I've
heard people who've played Fallout 4 uh
all these other Fallout games all of
these Oblivion games going into it full
well with knowing all the type of bugs
that these games are known for
being hyper critical of this game for
for those type of bugs a game that in
comparison to those games objectively
does not have as many books it just
doesn't
it is what it is man it's just we have
to weather the storm that's all and just
play the game
is my first Bethesda game I'm not an RPG
guy but I came in understanding what an
RPG game is and the time you need to
invest I was patient
put the time in and now I'm loving it
there you go nice loose Loop and we got
Nature Boy 80 five dollar Super Chat I'm
with King and Cog if those reviews I
enjoyed I enjoyed Callisto protocol and
it got rated terrible yeah I hated
Witcher 3 but everyone else loved it
just enjoy there you go absolutely there
you go I joke about you these guys don't
love red dead that's fine they can hate
it all they want
what you ain't gonna change my mind
about it that's for sure listen
I don't know people love getting into
that discourse and when you're young I
get it because you just like you know a
lot of your opinions are formed by what
your friends think this peer pressure
this whatever you old man
be thinking for yourself
I know hell no it's not happening okay
that's my dentures fit
oh no we got one more we got DJ auros
five dollar Super Chat at least it's a
close game hey bestie I heard we were
smacking out was it what was it 17 let's
see what's going on
go Niners
look halfway 65-yard tight TV 27-7
should have never started leave me alone
oh by the way I did I saw that that Izzy
video oh my God bro I've never seen
somebody get hit so many times without
any answer
somebody was hungry pumpkin at the
playground yeah man again that that goes
to show you any given Saturday night
I'm gonna be broke real quick I didn't
like how DJ became I mean Izzy been
handling the depressants I can't
pronounce that that I African on African
Violets the talks about it it's a little
too much and maybe he lost his Focus I
don't know but yeah
okay so my thoughts on the PS plus price
increase more alliteration yeah
Ah that's my topic yeah this is I'm
sorry I'm sorry in a moment we talk
about narratives and how narratives can
take on a life of their own and stuff
like that
this is not good man because it's just
an increase you're not offering me
anymore you're not giving me a reason
for it
um same as we gave Xbox smoke when they
were like yeah gold is gone but this is
you know in no game no reason they gave
no alternative at the time if you're
gonna do something like this you better
have something on Deck to explain to
people why this makes any type of damn
sense and you're just charging them more
for the same or less it does not make
any sense it is egregious especially
especially when you start talking about
the high tier and I'm gonna talk about
the tier that I'm in right I'm like okay
this is the tier that hopefully they
utilize to to bring back some measure of
real bad compact with PlayStation 3 it's
like hey you getting this money let's
see if we do this work and bring these
games back in a proper way right even if
it's a difficult thing to do do that
bro month to month maybe they've been
better about giving you a game in in the
in the the classics catalog or whatever
right
that's it that's it and then the whole
the cloud-saving stuff which I think is
is pertinent to the middle the middle
tier right so
um and then that base here is basically
just
get to play online or something
something to that nature all I know is
that the price jumps are egregious
in particular because there's nothing
added there is nothing whatsoever it is
just we are raising the price on you for
a service that already wasn't doing a
whole heck of a lot it is it really
really does not make any sense to me
um that coupled with this the closed off
nature of the of the PlayStation portal
and it not being able to do a whole lot
and no Bluetooth and it's like come on
like
it doesn't make any sense to me these
are not this it doesn't feel like you're
learning lessons here
um it just I really I I'm with this it
makes no damn sense to me and I'm not
one I usually just let my subscriptions
Rock I'm like I don't care whatever this
is the first time we're looking at like
why do I need this I don't need it I'm
gonna go buy a PlayStation one again and
get my old games back and play or or it
really it don't
they're not really they're not doing a
good job with this whatsoever and rather
than learn from Xbox and like hey man
let's try to put the value there let's
at least do the work to put the value
there the closest thing they've come to
it is that middle tier which is the most
that is that resembles Xbox apart from
not having the the day and Day games
which is the biggest part about it right
but at least the third party catalogs
are are comparable in that regard but
that low tier and that high tier in
particular egregious nothing there's
nothing there to Warrant you have it why
aren't you charging the price you were
already charging
forget about raising a price
um it doesn't make any sense to me but
again
we're not as Gamers we're not going to
make them pay for it
and we're gonna just go right along with
it and it'll be forgotten
that's it it'll be forgotten oh and it's
almost I remember when we first talked
about them employing the new tiers of PS
plus they were like and I said something
to the effect of like it feels like
something that they're doing in order to
say that they they tried and then
they're going to do egregious things or
not support it in the right way and say
hey we tried it didn't work we're gonna
cancel it and just give you one tier
because they never wanted to do the back
of patch stuff they never wanted to have
to give you these these old games they
never wanted to have to compete with
Game Pass in any way shape or form if it
were up to them none of this
subscription stuff would be on their
platform right so it it kind of does
feel like it's it's a step in that
direction like we're gonna make this so
egregious that everybody's gonna walk
away but I don't think they are because
if you're invested already
you may just forget about it and and
take that new whatever price and that's
it but it is no no no no no no shut up
and take it no bueno no no bueno no
bueno I appreciate yourselves I know you
gotta run so all right I have before we
but I have to do oh business business
so yeah business and then you go back to
the topic
hold on a second
all right
so this episode of The Iron Lords
podcast is brought to you by Factor
meals with the busy fall season just
around the corner I.E it's here already
you might be looking for wholesome
convenient meals for jam-packed days
Factor America's number one ready to eat
meal kit can help you fuel up fast with
Chef prepared dietitian approved
Ready-to-Eat meals delivered straight to
your door you'll save time you eat well
and stay on track with your healthy
lifestyle as summer comes to a close and
Autumn approaches that means changes in
the air whether it's the kids going back
to school which has happened already the
changes in the weather which is kind of
happening already or the impending
holiday season everyone is in a Mad Dash
to finish the year strong and like I
said changes in the air for everyone
except for me because for me winter
spring summer or fall I am always
working
so unfortunately the seasons meld into
one and it's a little difficult for me
to enjoy the other aspects of my life as
much as I should
one thing I can say for sure is that
lady Saab always makes sure that I walk
out of this house with my breakfast
lunch and dinner in tow and she does all
of this by being while being a working
professional herself what that means is
that at the end of the week you have two
very tired individuals looking for ways
to spend less time in the kitchen and
more time enjoying life and in comes
Factor meals when we started using
factor a while back I'm pleased to say
that it has been a hit we've been able
to cut our prep time in half by
replacing half of our weekly meals with
factor and it's been great whether it's
breakfast lunch dinner or snacks the
meals are fresh they're varied they're
healthy and easy to prepare just heat
them up for a few minutes and we're done
and Lady Saab has some of her sanity
back so if you're too busy with the your
end of summer goals to cook but want to
make sure you're eating well with Factor
skip the extra trip to the grocery store
and The Chopping prepping and cleaning
up as well while still getting the
flavor and nutritional quality that you
need factors fresh never frozen meals
already in just two minutes so all you
have to do is heat and enjoy and then
get back to crushing your goals
we have refresh your Healthy Habits
without missing a beat choose some 34
plus weekly flavor packed dietitian
approved meals ready to eat in two
minutes level up with Gourmet plus
options prepared to Perfection by chefs
and ready to eat in record time treat
yourself to upscale meals with premium
ingredients like broccolini leeks
truffle butter and asparagus
too busy running around during the day
to think about lunch think about uh keep
your energy up with lunch to go
effortless wholesome meals like grain
bowls and salad Toppers that are ready
to eat when you're on the go no
microwave required
looking for calorie conscious options
ahead of the busy season try delicious
dietitian improved calorie smart meals
with or around less than 550 calories
per serving
your Wellness goals and feel your best
for the rest of Summer try Protein Plus
meals with 30 grams of protein or more
per serving round out your meal and
replenish your snack Supply with an
assortment of 45 plus add-ons including
breakfast items like our delicious apple
cinnamon pancakes bacon and cheddar egg
bites which I love and potato bacon and
egg breakfast skillet which I also love
as you can tell I love breakfast food or
for an easy Wellness boost try
refreshing refreshing beverage options
like cold pressed juices shakes and
smoothies with Factor you can rest
assured you're making a sustainable
Choice as well they offset 100 of their
delivery emissions Source 100 renewable
electricity for their production sites
and offices and features sustainably
sourced Seafood in their meals this
August get factor and enjoy eating well
without the hassle simply choose your
meals and enjoy fresh flavor-packed
meals delivered to your door ready in
just two minutes no prep no mess so head
to factormills.com ion Lords 50 and use
code iron Lords 50 to get 50 off your
first order that's code iron Lords 50 at
factormeals.com
ironlords50 to get 50 off
yeah so what was that the Truffle bag it
was it was a lot of things
broccolini and truffle butter
have a great day sir shout out to factor
though
they hold it down again because
otherwise lady sock would be I I cook as
well but I just don't have the time
anymore so now it just gravitates to her
doing the majority of the cooking yeah
and uh uh yeah she would be like Sunday
she would be in the kitchen all freaking
day without Factor because at least we
cut some of that and we have these and
they're very good like they're very good
they're healthy so again we'll put the
code in the chat yeah I'll just put it
up and down yeah I'll get that 50 off
they are kind of pricey it can't be
pricey but they're worth it especially
if the plan is decent I mean they're
kind of not pricey like when you think
about all the ingredients and everything
that goes into it right yeah it's kind
of on par and it's kind of Cheaper yeah
if you Penny pinch and you're going like
and you're the type that's going to
supermarket and looking at every sort of
price or whatever they may be a little
pricey for you but again the 50 helps
immense basically and the fact that they
dropping it off at your door yeah like I
said yeah you just said go to the
supermarket
some healthy meals prepared sent to the
cribs you know single single cats you
know yeah do that you don't want to be
in the kitchen you want to be in the
kitchen
Hey listen let me let me give y'all a
hustle for you you're the house
don't be single no more yeah
how you how you how you bamboozled with
the game get your Factor meal come over
right do you have shorty come over you
take the fact out
have you ever seen like those those
videos where people act like they made
it yeah yeah
apologies because
my mouse stopped scrolling for a second
so I couldn't get the rest of the read
I'm like damn it I froze
the moment I try to pull out some stuff
like that Grace look at me like where'd
this come from
yeah
where did this come from this is too
well seasoned this is prepared to happen
well season that's I feel like that's
because I'm white girl so I appreciate
you brother I know you got a boogie all
right yeah I love y'all real quick I
gotta get this from you before you leave
because you're gonna miss it I'm dying
to know switch two coming in hot what
was you doing
I I already let me read these super
chats and and then I'll yeah thank you
yeah
let me see I had to get the
superchargers
yeah the fan funding that I love I only
seen color I love it
um Corey Tidwell two dollar Super Chat
I'm on NG plus three damn star I feel
this great that's crazy wow that's crazy
then we got gaming for a team member for
44 months Lord bronze can always count
on the Lords to be live when the Xfinity
app craps the bed and I can't watch my
NFL as always hey King Boo Boo hey shout
out to Forte's Lions even though he
don't be trying to claim them
then we have hargit chani ten dollars
almost finished with this terrible game
seven out of ten two generous three out
of ten no one should play this awful
game hashtag Xbox has no games
PlayStation pair should bend no
presentation wow whoa whoa I took a left
turn you don't get crap games like flop
field oh my God Jesus
then we have Danny passion officials
five dollar Super Chat loving Starfield
so far is the first uh Todd game that I
played over 10 hours but my last gaming
session on my PC with a 40 90
performance was pretty bad wow
um I don't it's just weird bro like it's
it's a PC problem it's definitely not a
4090 problem but it's a piece making it
working tweaking it's working apparently
there's a thing out there where the AMD
stuff is there's something going on with
the other stuff is not out before yeah
they outside
yeah
boy they making sure
at the end of the day AMD going to do
what they got to to make their brands
our Technologies workers it's it's on
Xbox and Bethesda not to take them bags
to do those optimization deals yeah my
chipset is inside the Xbox right it's
inside all the major consoles yeah
they've got the console game amd's got
the console game a lot the relationship
is crazy I mean they're just not working
with one console they got AMD in there
you're ridiculous that is because of
other business reasons I wonder what the
performance was over there let's see
continue so we got them unlimited time
and we have stitch stitch remember for
45 months Lord gold Starfield is
something you must experience to really
understand what this game is trying to
achieve I selected alien DNA yeah we
found the ship that had the initial
experiment files everyone was dead
I never found it I found a ship once
that was like the the robots took over
the ship and killed the whole crew
that's crazy I love doing that when I go
to a base and I turn the robots against
everybody
the friend of fro turret settings bro oh
those are fun there was a spacer that
was shooting at me from up above and he
dropped down and the robot sniped him
mid-junk he dropped down like in the
ragdoll physics oh it's so good yo the
vascos is no joke yeah but yeah right
they're basically Moscow
all right he the best fighter I like
when he punch him yeah oh my God I got a
clip where he body someone in the middle
of you talking to them in the cinema he
was just like oh you want to be
aggressive you have no choice of
defeating in the middle of someone
suited and knock home girl out I was
like yo it's in the chat stitching the
set yeah it's the PC Wars welcome to the
console Wars pretty much
then we got Big Country 94.5 pounds
super country big sorry not big country
yeah yeah five pound Super Chat evening
Lords 96 is the most hours I've ever put
into a game that game being AC Odyssey
yeah I know that 20 hours in the
Starfield now I already know it will
beat that shot the country big
professional wrestlers once you try it
you can't deny it that's it yeah yeah
then we got game before today five
dollars Super Chat no sir still living
living that Patriots life the Detroit
Lions are only a byproduct of this thing
he ain't claiming his kids but don't get
me wrong I'll still root for the Mac
Jones all right you got some Mac Jones
all right
yeah so quickly the switch two rooms
yeah real quick for you bro I mean
listen I when I initially heard it I'm
like no I need to I need confirmation
from yeah
I'm not trusting this so there's
multiple outlets now saying that this is
it meaning that they have some form of
Ray tracings
upscaling technology
again there must be something in that
water because again Nintendo is
notorious they're not going to lose
money on Hardware in fact so
I am interested to see what they do okay
um but again I wasn't believing it until
I had multiple corroborations so I'll
feel that let's see we'll see we'll see
but interesting nonetheless because it
shows a willingness to at least like
addicts it coming to the 24th century
jump to the 23rd chapter last one you
got faith and then we gotta roll out
face 23 became y20 live Super Chat Sony
trying to catch up to Game Pass ultimate
at over 180 a year
we're not the same level of services
not what with none of that yeah
but I see I see my face doing shout out
to Sony appreciate y'all
appreciate it love y'all I'm sorry I
gotta go go
it's a lot of rain in New York you gotta
hear a lot of rain New York all right
love y'all next week love you brother
all right it's you we're gonna set you
up all right I got it Nintendo stuck one
and follow the super track I try to tell
you all about that Integrity 239 with
dlss in the switch 2 lag last year but
China One listen we outside I think
you're gonna you're gonna like the topic
when we get to that you're gonna you're
gonna like that topic so um King you are
up we're gonna talk about that uh yeah
that increase man so um basically shout
out to um PlayStation blog Sony they
said that um I want to let you know it's
starting September 6th they will be
increasing the price of PlayStation plus
12 months subscriptions globally across
all benefit plans the price adjustment
will enable us to continue bringing high
quality games and value added benefits
to your PlayStation Plus subscription
services so they pretty much go on the
um the new prices so I'll tell you what
the prices are currently first so the
current prices the current price for
PlayStation Plus essential is uh 59.99
Playstation Plus extra is a hundred
dollars and then PlayStation Plus
premium is 119 so those were the these
are the currents right so as of
September 6 the prices is increasing
September 6 already passed oh yeah
correct oh yeah this is now correct
thank you so these prices have increased
by a staggering amount so now staggering
yeah from Place essentially went from
59.99 to 79.99
um actually went from 99 to
134.99 no that's that's 40 yeah yeah and
then premium went from 119.99 to
159.99 oh my God
yes he ridiculous so yeah yeah I'm not
for it though so pretty much they just
they ended the statement by saying the
new prices
they didn't say that wait they ended the
statement where we go out and deal with
it the new prices are 12. get a third
job will remain at a discounted rate
when comparing to the purchasing the one
month or the three month over the 12
month period for current 12 months
subscribe subscribers the price increase
will not take effect into your next
renewal date that occurs on or after so
you're in the old plan
as soon as that's over then it switches
up to the to the thing and it says
however any membership changes you make
on or after September 6th such as down
upgrades down grades or buying
additional time will update your plan to
the new prices so you can uh yeah change
or cancel your subscription anytime and
yeah that was pretty much the blog
nothing else but that so King this is
your topic where you at with this yeah
remember not too long ago Microsoft did
the uh two dollar update
they was like yeah you know Game Pass
we're gonna be raising that price for
the two dollars right before Starfield
came out dude just like oh my God they
raising the prices over there you dudes
your wild and two dollars a dollar nah
man that's not it I don't care about it
yo that raising the prices did they not
giving you anything back
nothing and I was like facts I can't I
can't I can't I can't rock with that you
know I wasn't in line step with
Microsoft raising prices but at the end
of the day man it's a dollar would you
could take it right you like all right
all right Microsoft he got me it's a
stick up he's a dog it's a dollar
Sony looked over so Microsoft doing the
stick up for the doctor dollar said I
can get these dudes for 40. beautiful
highest one though yeah yeah said now
the second one 42. like the last one is
only twenty dollars yo could you imagine
a panhandler walking up to you instead
of you all right so you got the
panhandlers to be like yo let me get
some change you're like no I ain't got
no change come and get a dollar bro let
me get a dollar
you'll be like all right man go ahead
man get this dollar yeah
could you imagine these aggressive
panhandlers running up to you let me get
forty dollars
yo let me get forty dollars I know you
got it got it come up off that 20 man
even though the panhand are not
providing you a service let's see but
see sometimes you can be like yo
panhandler dance for me I'm saying like
do something like Panhandle Panhandle
like Panhandle You Gotta Give me a
service like you gotta 99
cannot reduce
what what type of dance he got to do for
40.
like what type of paneling dance do they
got to do for forty dollars these dudes
told you
it's the same exact thing that you was
getting yesterday
yeah 40 dollars more
Oh Be Still your heart the dude whose
service ended on the seventh like be
still your heart when you sort of renew
come up you want to renew
if you want to be new Drake All right so
here's the scenario Tommy only got a
hundred and forty dollars inside his
bank account he said I'm covered with
this renewal for the PlayStation joint
all right and then I get my check I get
my check next week I'm good I have like
ten dollars in my account I'm good
they join up at the new price of them
you join his renewed at the new price
you overdraft now
you just paid another thirty dollars on
top of the forty dollars to think
you seventy dollars in on Sony's BS
that's that's a new game price like they
giving you they updating you up to the
next level without giving you a game yo
listen y'all want a date and date right
well good for you y'all gotta see your
stars and sunny said yeah we're gonna
give them seeing stars but we're gonna
charge these dudes 40 hours
I love them I love them it's better over
here it's better yeah
yo how does that 40 dollars feel y'all I
mean it feels icky to me it feels
disgusting because everybody wants the
best level the best level is 40 more and
then give it nothing extra in the Box
who the hell who is these dudes it's
telling you yo same thing that you've
been getting like let's say you get a
stick of naked cheese every day for work
every day for work let me get steak and
egg and cheese I got my lunch I gotta go
I gotta hurry up it's five dollars and
if dude you going in give me steak and
egg cheese all right cool and he said
that'd be 25
yesterday what did you put in there
truffle butter in there
please take the truffle butter out
because I can't pay the twenty dollars
boy you said you ain't getting that new
for this extra okay
[Music]
ooh the fact that y'all taking it with
y'all stop worrying about Starfield and
worry about what's going on
they worry about the wrong thing forget
about Metacritic this is a affecting
y'all ASAP right today today is the time
you're supposed to stand up no holding
in line for this I know you gotta fight
the day today the fight don't worry
about star fail don't worry about what
you can't play don't worry about
Metacritic it's forty dollars you know
what king they need to stop worrying
about startling start worrying about
what places you're gonna take from the
next
they're gonna take away the online part
you gonna pay forty dollars extra to
play offline
he's taking the best pause
please it ain't nothing like a
PlayStation fan God bless
you're ridiculous shout out to the king
you know I know he wanted to talk about
this anyway attic your thoughts uh um
yeah we was on uh was it uh Xbox two
being you and uh Fred outdoor came at
you he was like where's the same energy
with Xbox what is it uh Game Pass Court
came out he said you was Frontline you
was like this is amazing where's the
energy from attic
nice it's it's not the same thing you
know I felt like Xbox was you know
strategically putting stuff in place to
raise stuff you know artificially
um I would say the closest thing it's
one PlayStation because I I do feel like
PlayStation artificially raised the
price of PlayStation now they just broke
it up into tears and put PlayStation
Plus on it I would say that's more of
the same case but it's like at the same
time you know well what you gonna do
it's like you you're not gonna see
here's the thing I guess it would work
more on Playstation because I feel like
you know I know I'm wrong on this but
you know for me on Playstation I don't
need PlayStation Plus so they can keep
that money that's my money that's not
their money like I don't play none of
the multiplayer stuff over there but for
the people that play multiplayer stuff
over there
um damn
yeah you stupid it's like it's a big I
get I guess
I guess they they want your kids your
wife you know the next year they're
gonna try to take your mortgage you know
they want your house they want
everything like what's crazy is you know
it's a 30 increase that is the most
crazy like that is bizarre and what's
funny is like it's like they took the
last like couple years that they haven't
raised it it's like we're gonna get
these suckers for these last couple
years we ain't raised it and on top of
that we're gonna get that premium you
know we were gonna raise it by ten
percent but you play station people you
never say nothing so we're gonna raise
that up by another 20. I want a 30 tax
imagine imagine walking in to a to a
grocery store and there's a dude there
in a toe yeah how many I mean I mean 30
30 of what whatever you got on you right
now
I I used to be able to walk into this
store for free that was last today's
news today's news is different yesterday
it's like it's like if you don't give me
what I want
you turn it around you ain't shopping
here and don't think about going to the
Krogers down the road because our
employee Bob he's at the grocery store
that too you're gonna have to pay him
anyway it's like if you want what's in
this store you don't have to give me
that money
but but then you you know you you got
the you got the Walmarts and and the
Kmarts well that's Kmart's a bad example
they're gone so you got you know you got
the Walmarts the targets you know that's
the Microsoft the bigger stores they
walk in there okay last year we wanted
we wanted 10 from you to come in here
now we want 11. okay I guess I guess
that's better than 30 what you gonna do
you you you you you're gonna you're
gonna go back to the Krogers where they
want 30 to walk in the store
no you walking in that Walmart come over
to Walmart
I'll jump in um yeah this was this was
definitely shocking I didn't see it's
coming um to me it indicates two things
it's one I saw it coming I didn't see
that I saw a price increase in general
for all subscription services
but yeah I did this was substantial so
to me what that indicates is two things
one for them to raise it to this much
this amount means they needed to hit
their operating costs just for survival
I got to be honest right that you you've
cranked the numbers right you know what
it kind of reminds me of call it makes
me feel like you know Microsoft's
willing to take a little bit more of the
operating costs in order to get game
pass up and running because clearly
PlayStation is trying to compete in
think about you know the services a
little bit not not necessarily as much
as Microsoft but the crazy thing is you
know when Microsoft increases cost at
least I know star if it was going in
there and day and day fables going there
day and date so I could see even if they
raise it a couple more dollars I could
see some form of value PlayStation is
literally raising the prices of their
goods and then we're like What do I get
I mean you get to play online what did I
get last week you get to play online no
it's like they're not doing it and it
does feel like they're like look you
guys say you want more and PlayStation
Plus day and date like CS Stars we're
gonna give that to you but we're gonna
make you pay for it at the same time I
got something more Sinister yeah I mean
let me just
but um yeah no I get it to me like I
said operating course this is the
numbers they cranked out to survive and
we have to admit to me that's an
indication of a lack of growth in that
particular Subscription Service
um also to Kings Point k n news which
was violated true they stopped reporting
PlayStation Plus subscriber numbers that
is rare from them to not report they're
very transparent on their numbers and
their growth and then because they know
these numbers about the job so if if if
they're going to be stagnant then it's
like okay we'll if we lose some
subscribers right then obviously the
operating cost as well as getting now
more revenue from the less that you have
which means more money than what you
were getting prior so I think that's why
the jump is so substantial now to your
point attic I agree it's rough because
there's no extra incentive to the
customer now that you raise that price
it's literally just the troll money yeah
that that part is not gonna feel good
right like you do okay so you did raise
it you know another 40 hours okay so
what am I getting right and it's just
like well you're getting the same thing
that kind of thing you gotta Live
Another Day right so that that's what
that's gonna that's gonna be a loyal
loyalty test to to their base and you
know they'll they they can crack out the
numbers and see if they they can you
know withstand any drop and if not then
they'll be fine with the ones that they
do have paying more money and then
they're getting more Revenue you know
for me purposely it's the bigger picture
I am very curious the Xbox reaction
because I'm not popping bottles yet King
because not saying that they're gonna
Xbox is going to match that level of
increase because obviously you know
they've invested in Game Pass from a
long time and looking at it from a long
play and then it is Microsoft back at it
and we can't compare Sony's money to my
social money it's not you know big Bank
little Bank kind of energy so to me the
thing I look at is the price
subscriptions long term because at some
point once Microsoft is done with
whatever Acquisitions or whatever
whatever you know at some point the
price of Game Pass will raise right
we've already seen that one Starfield
came out you ain't getting no more
Dollar Deals bruh like it's like you
going with jump in call or you know
ultimate base whatever so that's the
thing to look at and in Sony's defense
remember when people were clowning 70
dollar games they jumped out there first
but eventually Microsoft everybody else
started taking soon right now
Subscription Service they're jumping out
here first let's see how long a year or
two if anyone else you know if Microsoft
kind of do that so that's something to
watch but yeah I was surprised by the
the sheer amount of it to me they
they're not getting more any more growth
in that area and they need this to
survive that's how that's how I look at
it so it is what it is okay
the fact of the matter is this just uh
mere weeks ago k n news reported to you
that Sony has decided to stop giving out
the numbers of their Subscription
Service true
and on the heels of that news Sony
decided to raise the prices true
now
I'm a confidential informant
that is under uh NDA
news yes it's got the recordings oh from
the actual meeting we got to record this
yes let me uh get those recordings oh
wow this is a k n exclusive y'all
what the hell you mean uh the
subscription Services uh um excuse me
what we down
we're gonna have to we're gonna have to
fit the bill oh hell no
oh hell no
um how is there any way we can push this
course over to the uh uh the customer
or for anything new no
man ain't gonna
what what's so what's so how much how
much we can we can raise it up by 15
each level
and we'll break even
how about we can gouge them for more
and we can fund the next game
Call of Duty is going someplace else we
need we need to be able to fund these
games I need to make more DLC we got
Spider-Man coming out in a minute that's
another thing yeah you'll see that we
got going on can't lose any money
okay can't be can't have money funny
money it's a go it's a go We're Not
Gonna fit the bill we ain't gonna we
ain't gonna absorb the cost of the loss
we're gonna pass that on to the customer
that was direct
I was from okay wow wow so you know see
I had it confidential you had under the
table when he was recording the
situation it's nuts was going on over
there though but we know this to be true
because they have passed those uh that
bill on y'all so could you imagine
somebody offering you to come out to eat
y'all go out and I eat at a great
restaurant
and the Bill come out and they look at
you when they slide
so I'm not gonna eat that it was a
little bit more tonight
it's like you go out I have to eat on
your birthday and you think you know
people like yo let's go out to eat for
your birthday you get there you sit
there you eat you're like yo this is lit
and then at the end of that meal they
look at you be like are you paid it's my
birthday
[Music]
's free
they should have a Metacritic for the
price you have to play for yourself
but then all services should be under
Metacritic to see if the service is
living up what sir what number you gonna
get this one you got somebody dude
you're ridiculous is this a seven damn
you're ridiculous anyway instead of
worrying about a lot of piss jobs
you need to find out who raised the
practice
and not God need to go just y'all your
priorities are screwed up mixed up and
turned around yeah yeah listen let me
get y'all focused in the right direction
that God has told you to go out there to
cause all this trouble
one that smacked you
and he's charging you forty dollars per
smack listen go back over there handle
your business I want to see y'all now I
want to see how true it is for you Sony
dudes if you're really about this if
you're really gonna stand up and be as
vocal as y'all are every day on X I want
to know if y'all gonna be vocal on this
right here
where's the out notice King that like
that since
since this was announced it was talked
about people maybe like one or two
tweets about it but now everyone's like
okay now now that I have publicly said I
was against it now I could just go back
to my life and you know just pay this
extra couple bucks like I feel like
people
the only reason I saw some people speak
about is I really do feel like they were
just like I don't want to be looked at
as that that you know that consumer or
that PlayStation fan that didn't speak
out against it but I really don't care
like I I it just to me there wasn't a
lot I did see a lot of people sitting
there canceling it and you know
I guess you could argue that right now
unless you play like you know Call of
Duty I mean those are free to play games
so you wouldn't need it for them like
what do you need an online
infrastructure if you play like 2K
Madden most likely yeah you know I know
a lot of people that play Madden offline
they don't really play it online a whole
lot I know a lot of people that play you
know 2K franchise so you don't really
need it for that only if you really play
online this game's still low-key
required online just to move around and
and fun but no I I'm talking about
needing the subscription service to play
online so it's just like well you can
make that argument that a lot of
PlayStation games
you don't really need that that
subscription like on Xbox no no you do
you do remember or Cloud saves is tied
to it if you don't have what you call it
um PlayStation Plus you don't have Cloud
slaves so you can't if y'all yes that's
another thing why are we putting Cloud
saves behind a paywall
that's it listen I I need the service
because I'm not running out and buying a
bunch of their game bless you so the
games that I do have that I you know I
want to try certain stuff that they do
happen to drop over there so I'm a
little beholden to it because you have a
vast uh catalog that you're able to dip
into and play games here and there
um
and and like you said that cloud safe
thing that's kind of strange how you put
that behind a page wall that's kind of
weird but there's no added value all
joking aside
you raised the price but you didn't give
anything else right right and and the
only thing that I can say that happened
that was different was sea of stars was
that was a nice guy yeah right but
trying to see a Stars looking over at
game passes inside Game Pass and Game
Pass model is built so this is this is
where I gotta believe cog's philosophy
and what he believes is the service
models is two a dichotomy of two
different worlds one world
is the platform is Game Pass don't don't
get anything twisted if Microsoft is
going to tell you that Xbox is the
platform that's absolute lie the
platform is game pass because that's the
vehicle that's going to get those games
to everything they want their thinking
outside of the box
PlayStation
thought process is PlayStation box is
the vehicle so they're still reporting
uh sales numbers in the old metrics and
the service is an additive to said box
the box is the Gateway the box is the
end-all be off and
they're losing money on services
the box is not enough because there's
the ceiling is there at 120 million Peak
they haven't even you know got close to
that so obviously in this new day and
age
they're not making enough money
they can't give you service worry about
the Box not reaching its peak without
raising price at some point yeah and to
attic's point
maybe they are going to cancel something
maybe there are uh going to eliminate a
tear to say that this thing didn't work
out you know
um maybe that's the ultimate goal for
them later on to just actually defund
the whole service itself and say it was
a failed product because remember
PlayStation Now was a failed product and
then they rolled it into the PlayStation
service and they thought those numbers
would inflate and now going back saying
that you're not going to report numbers
this Troublesome looking at this I've
told you guys before on numerous
occasions
it's not the same Sony
you're gonna start seeing stumbling
you're going to start seeing no they're
at the same caliber they're pushing out
the same levels they're doing the same
things everything is pointing towards
crisis
everything is pointing towards this
won't keep continuing
how much money do you think they're
going to start charging you 200 to have
the service no how much till the public
Rebels
my console and service is going to be a
rebellion in that part because you're
not getting value for what they're
asking look I hear you kicking this is
as funny as I was in the ls subject will
you be going off on this they think that
I am lockstep in agreement with you and
I'm like that's my cousin like that's
how he feel but I will say even though I
disagree with some things that you
believe what you say right everything
and then into your credit your track
record especially this generation has
been on fire so it's been hard to combat
you lately because a lot of things you
say have come to fruition so look all
I'm gonna say is yeah these are definite
signs that there is some things going on
there they're in a transition period
obviously they tried to Pivot to
Services right by yourself with all in
both feet okay they kind of dipped see
what was going in one toe all right
let's see then we started off with
legendary collection and that kind of
change then he did the PlayStation Plus
the tears you know it wasn't the day and
Day stuff that's what but again to me I
just don't think it's ascended as you
think that's the only difference I I
still think we're like a generation off
but I do agree with you that there are
signs that are interesting to me right
right when you stop again for the most
transparent company to stop reporting
numbers for this you know for and this
service is not
that old yet I mean PlayStation Plus has
existed but when they came out with a
tier system thing that I feel is fairly
new or correct right isn't that when
they came out with the plus the central
there's that I feel that hasn't lasted
that long so to me this is a pivot
you've got to cover course you've got to
make money and and to me they're not
ready to do day and day they are con
content with PC one year later whatever
console is everything to them still and
we'll see we'll see but I just trust me
I I listen to what you say I listen to
what you say we it's just going to be
one of those things that I I just have
to be if it just happened critically and
then you will get I know I'm gonna get
the ultimate I told you so you know what
I'm saying I'll happily take my L if you
are proven correct I still think just
their investment in Council and the
success there my my actually trepidation
is a little different my only
trepidation with them is
the consistency of first party title
Cadence versus Microsoft right where
it's like two a year three a year one is
not really fully exclude you know what I
mean like that when it comes down to
when it's like okay you can say what you
want but it's Hi-Fi Rush it's um Age of
Empires it's you know Minecraft Legends
yes yeah red four okay fine star field
it's Forza you know what I mean like if
this that continues to happen right
that's hard to beat
that that I've always said that that
Cadence can get if my because we thought
that was going to be 2001 2001 when it
was publishing year we thought that they
had the stumbling block with 2002 but
now 2003 23 they look like they back on
and we know 24 is pretty stacked right
we still got a vow you still got hell uh
what's called hellblade so we'll see
that's it but that's all I got on this
guy I'm sorry I think if anything this
does show that you know I I'm not there
with with King saying there's not a ps6
I I think there's definitely because you
know for the record everyone and other
could think we are lockstep 100
no there's gonna be a ps6 you know okay
I think I think that's going to be a
dark day for King but anyway now mind
you if you lose this week he's gonna add
this one
the problem is but the problem is and I
love you and I only say this to say this
to just for you but for no one else just
for you
every company that disappeared
always had the next thing in the chamber
being researched and developed so
anytime if you're trying to base your
logic off of the fact that I've heard
that they have this in development
they're coming they just gonna happen I
feel you I've been there to know months
before releasing said product
we shut it down it ain't happening yeah
it's gonna happen I just can't wait to
be there yeah we're going to get to a
point where they're going to announce
the ps6 because you're like it's gonna
get shut down before it happens yeah
exactly
when I when I when I'ma literally be
with the PSG controlling their hair
I know what he's gonna do you know
what's funny let's say we we blow up
between now and then and they want to
sit and put I would love if they sent
him a ps6 with me you know what's crazy
there's people out there with M2
machines
really I really I really want you to
take this trepidation that you have see
because you got this thing in your chest
is beating there's people out there with
Nintendo PlayStations
yeah okay so your heart is ah they up
man what's crazy you act like phony we
good partner
we going with CDI put your joint back in
the box
right about that and we've seen stuff
we've seen stuff going on right
regardless with that situation I think
this has shown
that
PlayStation's mentality might be PS3
again like the shows that they can do
whatever they want there's no
repercussions there's no consequences I
mean just just look at the past couple
years they they have you know did the
the thing where they you know the third
tier that's in the PlayStation essential
the only PlayStation people tell me that
tier is literally useless there's
nothing of value there you know they
raised prices they they have completely
went away from you know the first party
over the uh shoulder thing clearly
they're still doing it but even Colin
brought up that chart that says within a
couple years 60 of their funding is
going to go towards games as a service
so it's just like
they are clearly and what I will agree
with King is they're clearly shifting as
a company they're no longer the
PlayStation 4 uh team they they have
different requirements PlayStation 4
used to you know Sean late and all them
to me their mindset was we make good
games the money will come
uh but it seems like you know Jim his
mindset is we're gonna make games for
the money to come
you know we're not we don't care about
what type of games we're making we're
gonna make games that's gonna be a bank
and obviously there's there's different
variety of banks they're going to want
like a Chase bank but you know they
might end up getting like a local City
Bank that's only two places in the world
so it just depends on what happens but
you know if anything this really does
show that it's like look like this isn't
the same PlayStation
100. ever since Sean I mean really get
down ever since Sean left I would say
there was that time where even when Phil
left it was still part of the old regime
they're games that they signed right now
is Phil's regime 100 correct uh I think
you're starting to see Jim's Vision now
yeah you're starting to see a lot of the
decisions that he made when he first
took over come to fruition right now and
it could it could really benefit from
them it could but there is a realm where
let's say a couple of these games as a
service blows off and they got a
fortnight or something and they're able
to really Captivate this generating
money with these games as a service what
happens to the god wars in the recourse
where he's going to these these these
shares and he's like look we lit over
here
especially funny especially why are we
spending more money into stuff that's
not making the money that this money
makes right especially if one of the
live Services they create pop off
absolutely and we know they that's part
of the reason why they acquired Bungie
10 lab service games yeah they want they
want that revenue and we know that you
know that's why he's going to was not
green lit that you know there's a lot of
things they're going to remaster remake
some of their Blockbusters and they're
going to attack live service so yeah and
that's another thing Sony used to like
really be
extra with like promoting and giving IPS
a shot you know they used to make a lot
of new IPS but you don't really see that
anymore you know what what's the the
rumors we hear now we we hear a horizon
forbidden West remake A Last of Us to
remake The Last of Us three like you
don't really hear the light the last
time you know we don't really hear too
much of them making a new IP anymore you
know there was rumors that that the
people who make uh ghost of sushima was
it returned to a new IP though return
but they bought that that was being
bought uh that that was being made
before the company and they bought it so
you know I wouldn't they didn't buy the
company but they they funded the game
you know I don't know what they're gonna
do but even that you know I heard that
game didn't even sell well at all like
it it was a huge commercial flop to like
PlayStation standards so it's just like
what what what is the future of
PlayStation and I see a lot of Hardcore
PlayStation people just not liking the
moves that he's that Jim's making you
know I mean they got an important show
let's be honest and kings was part of
Hold the Line blue is that King was
Fearless coming into the PlayStation
show because the reason why hola was
popping and was such a movement is
because it's the red four thing CMA
block and then PlayStation show was
imminent and based on past old regime
PlayStation energy most people were
expected a dominant PlayStation and I
feel like Sean Lake never would have let
that show happen right and then it was
underwhelming and the PlayStation based
themselves were very disappointed in
that show so they have a lot to prove
since that show on for their next show
to get the bass back up and then we did
know that a lot of their first parties
that maybe they had playing got moved
out of of this year so yeah they got
some important stuff that they have to
do so that is one of the incidences
where I had to give King his flowers
because we all was like yo they come
into this fight they're gonna hit us
with Bazookas they gonna hit us with
bangers back to back and we didn't get
that let's move on because we all
beating this one to death but um unless
you got anything else King you got nope
fantastic
you got the uh super chats ready
No Doubt
all right uh hello my my thing is
messing up
um remember for 36 months drunken ninja
Bethesda put their meat on the table
with Starfield and gamers are scared
five dollars to drop from Godzilla they
doing gym dance move Ryan's special for
the 40-day panhandling yeah yo he's Wild
that's all that's it oh okay cool no
doubt wait for King to come back unless
there's like merchandise that's been
sold um I'll check I didn't see
double check walking ready let's look at
the marriage situation
um a couple
[Applause]
yes some of what the leggings the
spandex joints in red oh no doubt we got
that today also um log net you got we
got the log net jump off that's good to
see laws of gaming you know what I'm
saying then I believe uh last week uh
look like hold the line a couple of Hold
the Line actually three Hold the Line
t-shirts at a cup and a mug oh they went
crazy for Hold the Line last week so
salute but yeah shout out to you and
them red of hot red leggings whoever
we haven't picked that out you'll say
well get sexy with it with IOP I see you
okay
shout out to see Mama you kid you good
to go
and you said something about leggings
I'm sorry they got the hot red leggings
if
oh they per oh yeah yeah
get sexy for the day
I'm ready all right meet your bikes
everybody everybody Mutual mics
this is my peoples that meant mobiles
after years of fine print contracts and
getting ripped off by big Wireless
providers we if we learned anything it's
that there's always a catch so when I
first heard meant mobile offers premium
Wireless starting at 15 bucks a month I
thought what was the catch
but after talking to him and using that
service it all makes sense
there isn't one mint mobile secret
sources that they're the first company
to sell wireless service online only
they cut out the calls from the retail
stores and pass those sweet savings
directly on to you
now I'm like Sony
our people at mint mobile said we're
going to give this course right back to
you guys and um you know the savings is
fantastic uh you know my son has got his
mobile phone and it kind of put my mind
at ease to be honest with you because
having a phone I think every parent
should have this peace of mind that they
can call a kid and get in contact with
them at emergencies or just to check up
on them or just to have that rapport
with them that they're always in contact
is so Min mobile allows that to be a
whole lot cheaper and for me you know
everything is you know navigating this
world financially has become a little
bit of a trick so to get some Savings in
a place that is essential goes a long
long way for me goes a long long way for
my son and gives me that peace of mind
so him using the service and the quality
is good every time I call them it's it's
clear it's not like yo I'm under a
bridge or something you know it's I'm
always able to reach him and that peace
of mind goes a long long way so I'll be
honest with you people to get this type
of Premium server for 15 bucks it's it's
nuts to me whereas you know normally I
was using other services and it just you
know really didn't go as well as well as
I thought it would
for anyone who hates their phone bill
mint mobile offers Wireless for just 15
bucks a month and mint mobile gives you
the best rate whether you're buying for
one or a whole family mint mobile starts
at two lines all plans come up with
unlimited talk text high-speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5G
Network use your own phone with any mint
Mobile plan and keep your same phone
number along with all your existing
contacts switch to Mint mobile and get
premium wireless service starting at 15
bucks a month
to get your new Wireless plan for just
15 bucks get the plan shipped to your
door for free go to mintmobile.com slash
Iron Lords that's mintmobile.com slash
Iron Lords cut your wireless bill to 15
bucks a month at mintmobile.com slash
Iron Lords
no doubt no doubt getting that mint
mobile up here you know what I'm saying
I'm saying it works let me get the um
the link up in there salute to the good
peoples over there hold on one second
we're gonna put that up in there right
now yeah so that link should be right up
in there you'll be real surprised at the
Quality that you get for 15 bucks
putting that up in there go check it out
and yeah that's and it's like you said
like you know I don't have a kid but if
I had a kid they'd be getting this it's
like the Game Pass effect it's like for
15 a month I keep you well it'll be 30
at that point 30 a month I keep you safe
communicating and and entertain all my
yeah
no doubt so we gonna move on this is me
yeah y'all know what's up my favorite
topic to talk about switch covered in
hot y'all a lot of switch news in these
streets a lot of switch to Roma's
running around shout out the warrior 64
kind of kind of broke kind of the
aggregate of it initially and then shout
out to Eurogamer and good friend to Rum
Jazz Corden yeah developer presentations
for switch two took place behind closed
doors at Gamescom your game understands
what Partners showing tech tech demos of
how well the system was run
um one switch to demo is a souped up
version of switch launch title breath of
the wild designed to hit the switch to
be fear targets facts to be clear though
it was just attack demo there's no
suggestion that a breath of the wild uh
remake or whatever is being you know put
out there um per video game uh Chronicle
switch 2 was allegedly running the
Matrix unreal 5 Live tech demo that was
originally released originally showcased
the power of PlayStation 5 and series X
in 2021
now running on target specs for switch 2
using nvidia's dlss upscaling technology
with Advanced raytration Ray tracing
enabled and visuals comparable to Sony
and Microsoft's current gen consoles
allowing developers to achieve higher
graphical settings and better frame
rates on weaker Hardware
um notably Nintendo had also filed
patents for potential AI upscaling
technology plans back in March 20 20
2020. so
um yeah how we how we feeling about
these switch to rumors attic how we love
what's going on out here is it coming in
hot for you
I just got to see the games yeah I it'd
be stupid if you did a if you built a
build of breath of the wild or tears of
Kingdom I don't know which one they put
on here maybe both the first one the
first one you didn't release it uh if
anything that makes me know that there
is no backwards compatibility on this
thing
um you know
I'd be very surprised at this point you
know they could be they could surprise
us but to me I'll launch a console with
no game
no they'll launch it with with switch
two games oh you worry about backup Pat
okay
Nintendo are experts at making you pay
for their old games uh it seems like not
only are they experts at making you pay
for your own games they're experts at
making you pay a subscription service
for their old games you even own it you
got to pay them forever for that stuff
all right but whatever uh so for what it
was what if we saw a series X students
and PlayStation 5 levels and and it's
looking good what's up third parties and
regular Nintendo first party looking you
know y'all always say y'all say do you
see this Tech that's it here
we've seen that media kits and we've
seen that Dev kits uh they they are a
variety of different from the actual
console is I think I I was told once
that the series X was the dev kit was
twice as strong as the actual console
you know uh they could have just been
showing the dev kit just to make sure
they get uh just to show what the games
will run I mean here's the thing
Nintendo's gonna want to hit a good
price point uh especially if it's a
handheld you're right if it's that
strong I don't think it's a handheld
um uh because how are you going to
handle that much power you know we we're
going to play something for 10 minutes
and it dies oh I see it because they got
to prioritize battery life yeah so it's
just like you know
maybe it's a hybrid that when you when
you dock it the doc actually does
something more than just projects maybe
it it enhances the switch and it plays
it on good frame I don't know but to me
the thing that just doesn't sit right is
if it's on a PlayStation 5 level and a
especially portable we've seen with with
the handhelds you guys have they're not
cheap no they're not but I mean uh it is
NVIDIA dlss and dlss does allow you to
get better graphics on weaker Hardware
people really the PC Community really
Raves about DLS that's to the point
where I believe even with Starfield they
were amazing three 400 weaker Hardware
though I mean but according to if all
right let's let's look at what we the
rubies we know right which is Bobby
stitches saying that it's definitely
more on the power of a PS4 like or
hybrid more than appear that makes more
sense to me right then so let's just say
it's PS4 level right with dlss upscaling
to make it look resolution wise and it's
running unreal five which is current gen
right so let's just say they they can
upscale uh the 720 to the 1080 or
whatever that don't appeal to you at all
not really well most of the the third
party stuff too you know we talk about
first party I'm always gonna like a game
that runs better so you know and I
usually review the games uh here
recently and they have been very rough
like the the X the switch games you know
tears of the Kingdom that was a couple
times it was a consistent type of
experience but there's sometimes I'm
like man this this game rough uh so it
just it just depends man it depends on
what they're comfortable with that price
point is because I'm sorry I think
they're gonna try to hit like a 350
price range like I think that they're
not gonna like here's the thing okay
you're they need to get to that point
where people feel comfortable going
because look if
what has benefited them is the big
households the three to four kid
households that they're like okay let's
just go out and pick up these 200 uh you
know switch lights or how much they are
these days and let's buy three of them
for 600. if you get that up and now
you're adding another 100 okay if I got
four kids three kids why buy them
individual switches when I could just
buy them one console and just let them
all play that and it's just like because
the more that price is the more it's
going to be to accommodate to multiple
children they've always done well
because they've been at a cheap point
where it'll cost you a little Penny but
it's different than going out and buying
Timmy Tommy and Tina uh you know a
series X each which is fifteen hundred
dollars then buying tinny Tina Tommy and
Tina buying them a a switch for 300 each
because that 200 might not matter in the
grand skimming things off of One console
but when you're buying multiple but
that's when it starts to happen 300 off
the rip when they first yeah that was
300 when they first no no I'm talking
about if we're going to the four to five
because you talk people sit there talk
about it's going to be PlayStation fives
no no they're not saying PlayStation 5
spec they just said comparable
I just feel like
people need to relax okay until we
actually see the actual console uh
because
it's cute what we hear it's gonna be you
don't believe them because you think
that their price is gonna be a factor to
bring it down some of this technology
that we see and people are sitting there
listening you know just court and all
them I'm sure that actually happened
yeah
what is actually going to be the price
point are they going to be able to do
that realistically in the market that
they currently are in keep in mind you
got the uh the handheld Market has
drastically improved in the past couple
years they have that to worry about as
well it's no longer you know they'll
have the Pokemons in the in the Marios
and the zeldas to help them out Nintendo
got the games come on but those games
come out they don't come out every year
anymore you know it took five years to
get Zelda we haven't seen a 3D Mario
since since like 2016. Metro Prime fours
took like a decade to make like maybe
they held it out for the no no I don't
think Metro force is a launch title uh
metroids have never sold very well uh
for the most part uh I think they are
launching a 3D Mario for for the switch
too uh it's just you know I hope it is I
opened all that for 300 but I think we
can all agree that if they have to
breach that 300 and go to the 400 range
I don't know if they could sell a 400
switch now they're gonna sell 400 with a
blue map with a new Mario
boy
for a little bit more you can get a
steam deck they have another one coming
out ain't got no Mario
yeah it's a lot though man I feel you
listen you're making available I know
exactly what you're saying I'm just
messing with you it's it's gonna be
interesting if if based on attacking the
price ratio so if if you're good I want
to get kick on this I'm curious if
you're good at it
yeah good oh okay
um yeah let's get um
no hold up let me address some of the
challenges I'm not saying that they
would never sell 400 switches I'm saying
that one of the Prime reasons that they
had so much success with the switch that
they currently are selling was the low
entry that you could you could buy
multiple times for multiple kids once
you raise that even by a hundred
we're talking two or three hundred
dollars you got three kids of three
extra hundred dollars you got to spend
on getting oh hold on we got Nadine who
we met at Pax West with with kind of
crew and and Nintendo N64 Josh he was
like yo the OLED was 350 dudes they had
no problem
that was different because there was a
standard switch that you could buy okay
they also have the switch light that was
cheaper there was a variety of things
that you could do all right they might
do that in the in the switch too life
cycle eventually but at launch they're
going to be if it's 400 it will sell
well okay but the problem is is are they
going to have the same success that the
switch they currently have now has and I
think the higher that margining on that
price is they'll have a don't get me
wrong they're still going to sell a lot
it's just the higher that is like I said
I know families that have four or five
switches
if that was a hundred hundred fifty
dollars more per kid they might not have
four or five switches they might have
two or three switches or may have a
series X or a PS5 in their house Dad
switch I don't touch that one
that's King
Wiggles no this is a good point it's a
good these are great Point that's I love
this I was hoping to see what you say
for it but if you're good I got I wanted
to ask King if you're good at it it'll
be good yeah Okay cool so
you know a lot of new technology dlss
Unreal Engine five oh wait how we
failing okay well um I believe
everything will be true
shout out to K N news I was TI's that
were on the floor had uh Pax uh West yes
uh as we were in the air and we were
flying away I was getting a whole bunch
of texts and you know on our background
chatter we uh heard that they were
showing yeah now from what I hear Final
Fantasy Final Fantasy VII uh oh we're
showing on it big cloud outside on a new
switch to a bluff a breath of the wild
60 frames per second at a higher
resolution was shown oh
um that's coming in from the specs that
they saw that was supposed to be 12 gigs
of RAM I don't put too much uh weight
behind that I probably think a little
bit somewhere like around eight I think
that probably the dev kid probably had
12. okay oh yeah um I think it'll
probably uh you know come down to
somewhere between that Ram course that
range yeah of course yeah I think it's
six and eight okay okay in between yeah
they're not they're not showing this to
Consumers they're showing it to me this
is this is media and oh and CEOs uh
heads heads of uh heads of Publishers
and stuff of of the Publishers that's
going to be getting these games to you
now here's where you can look and see
the tea leaves all right let's go
Phillips not gonna give these guys a
10-year contract on Call of Duty of
course
Phil already do it dominance already
though
he's done what it's been like for for
years yeah this was this he added the
switch so here's the thing they have Dev
kits for it they yeah
and dudes wanted to realize uh trying to
figure out what what what is
the switch being on a field shelf though
what's what's going on
right so everybody was leading and
thinking it's current switch and it
probably would be current switch you
probably have a streaming version of
Call of Duty that's on the current
switch right but natively it's going to
run natively on the switch too so that
uh I think the the overall Graphics of
the machine is going to be Top Notch I
think the resolution on the if it's a a
switch in the traditional sense of we
know what switch is that you can have
all right the rumors are still
maintaining
off the dock and probably 1080p on 900
um when it's docked okay okay I think 60
frames per second will ring Supreme on
the machine and I think that's achieved
through uh dlss uh from Nvidia and their
techniques that there's they're using
that's proprietary towards their
chipsets facts they got detergents with
them in the beginning they've been with
Nvidia nice little in pocket and this is
their it's it's Hardware not software
that's the difference between AMD and
the difference between Nvidia the AMD
stuff works with everything everyone
yeah and Nvidia stuff is proprietary so
a lot of the stuff that Microsoft and
and do you have a game pass on the on
the machine that's something totally
different down the block right later on
I I my question for this machine
do you have a dual slot where you put in
a switch card and it's back up half a
switch because you're going to have
different storage medium
is the storage medium cartridge so they
can keep the fast data transfer if they
find a way to realistically make a
larger cartridge larger in size form
fact and shape that can hold a greater
capacity for video game gigs right going
in so or would they rely on their
Network which they're partnering with
Microsoft at some point in time uh to
have the network offload a lot of the
cloud stuff listen
it's a lot of moving parts that's true
what we do know is we are closer to a
switch 2 coming out
is it going to have the projection stuff
that I set would would that be the trick
we are hearing the specs we're hearing
about the games but we're not hearing
the hook yes Nintendo always has a hook
to pull you in true none of this stuff
that we've heard so far is a big enough
hook for you to say I gotta switch let
me go up you know and it's not just the
games Nintendo always has to change the
way we see play and feel in no games in
order to get you to experience what they
trying to bring across have we had
confirmation that it is definitely a
handheld or the latest part yeah the
rumors hold on I did but I would assume
it's a handheld but with Nintendo you
don't know like I'm assuming it's it's a
hybrid I said although this is from uh
video game Chronicle although specific
details of the hardware are being kept
closely guarded VGC sources indicate
that the next gen console will be able
to be used in portable mode similar to
the Nintendo switch so the rumor still
suggests that the phone it's a hybrid
it's a hybrid on some level right it's
that that's pretty self-explanatory I
would be very surprised that they didn't
you know because that that that that was
lightning in a bottle yeah well they've
been that way since the Wii U just as
you know uh some of the people that we
talked to in the background the initial
concept of the Wii U was wrong it was
you know talking to engineer Engineers
that's in the industry and I'm talking
about top-notch leading into Engineers
that's in the industry that can make
consoles and have these brainstorming
meetings Nintendo was on the right track
just with the Wii U they did it
backwards all the text should have been
in the handheld correct opposed to the
the base so when they got it right there
was always on the right track but when
they got it right they got it right with
the switch and I believe they're going
to keep that same mentality because the
engineers in the industry as a whole
knows where we're moving if you're
seeing uh um uh an explosion of handheld
devices that are powerful in the
industry that we see right now as far as
the the lavio or the level giant the
Lenovo uh joint
um the rug the steam deck these machines
are capable they're they're larger in
size as far as uh graphics and
everything like that but it doesn't fit
Nintendo's model to go too high in price
I believe addict when he says that price
point is key yeah so they're not going
to do anything to knock theirself out of
making money from initial
with the family friendly pricing that
they go through with three hundred
dollars I don't think it's more than
three hundred dollars I think it hits
300 price point so at that three they
might do a skew though higher higher end
switch too for like more storage or
something they'll do a skew but there's
going to be an entry I guarantee you
it's 300 like you know maybe they feel
like inflation and stuff they can get
away with four hundred dollars
do you think they do they do something
where you can put your own
uh Nintendo memory card in the in the
machine to up the ram that's inside the
initial box I I doubt it but um do you
think that's something that there
I I don't think I just think this is one
of those things where what can Nintendo
what does Nintendo feel like they can
get away with and what they can
realistically get away with
um I don't I don't know like because
here's the thing like that one of the
reasons that they were mad successful is
just the entry was so low they could do
it multiple ways and it's just like once
you raise that you know because I don't
think that out price he's a casual but I
think that goes away from being less of
an Impulse buy and you know switches
were really good on impulse buys I know
so many people that would walk in my
cousin storm walked in this up a a
Walmart one day impulse buy the switch
he that's been his primary console this
entire entire generation it's just but
because it was at a price where you
could do that you know talking 400 you
know uh it's like I said I I think that
would sell very well it's just will they
have the success they have now that they
had right during the switch that's the
question if King is good I was gonna
jump unless you're good no I'm perfect
yeah look
I'm feeling this
ah feels good right now I'm feeling
right now let me tell you why because
switches the first one it's the most
successful console they ever had let's
be real and this was my number one draft
pick I told everybody more successful I
told you more success everybody down now
oh I mean we I don't know you can look
at those yeah I think they're weird look
at those numbers but it's one of their
most successful console it is my it's my
number one draft pick I told people
what's going to have people laughed at
me I said I'm that guy in the commercial
I'm that guy that went from the from the
couch to the flight I wasn't the guy on
the basketball court with the switch I
wasn't that guy but you know the guys in
the club but they had the commercials
it is on the rooftop party or whatever
with that guy but I was the guy that
tribe was jump on the plane I was like
they got it form factor they took it the
next step past the Vita with the the
double shifts the Dual analogs
full functionality I was like boom to me
it was time right they've milked this
thing the games have still been great
but we've seen it starting to show its
age we've seen as far as the hardware
and they would shout out to that Tegra
chip they these developers out here
doing the Lord's work is sorcery even
porting things down to this platform as
it currently is so I always feel
Nintendo with power is intriguing to me
they've always if they got power once I
heard Unreal Engine 5 Matrix demo
running that demo is crazy
there's a lot that demo is the fact that
well is it running the fact that it's
running it's running really good the
factors
developers shift games out say this game
runs well they say comparable to series
X comparable is all I need to hear the
reason why is it at a lower resolution
you see people get caught up with okay
that stuff was running on the
PlayStation 5 and the Xbox 4K yeah you
know so this doesn't have to push out
yeah I look at it like series that's
level you don't gotta goal you don't
gotta do 4K you ain't got to do that you
got and then the fact that they win the
Nvidia yeah already who have a great
Hardware relationship get the chips for
cheap knows the hardware software in and
out using their dlss technology this is
a
for Nintendo perfect because it keeps
them current it keeps them within
Striking Distance you don't have to be
on the level of these guys but you're in
Striking Distance you can still do a
little low-res version in your joint and
you Gucci and if this Tech is as good as
it people say they've invested patents
in upscale Tech like that that means
they're taking it serious the form
factor I agree with you addict has to be
key or indicators feel that it's going
to be there
um the dock boost most likely when it's
in dock like King was saying get you a
little extra bump the portability you
know and to me this is the key now this
is where I put you at it
the price is going to be key before
another reason
the problem as much as I love my Ally
and as much as I love my steam deck
these batteries are atrocious yep
these batteries are you have to live
with that plug I'm on the plane plugged
in I'm not even playing around you know
what I'm saying because you're going to
get them high performance gains you're
getting an hour or two now this is where
addict's questioning is very valid
because if you're gonna have some of
this power right if you're gonna have
some you know
can Nvidia work sorcery as well as
Nintendo with this battery life now if
they're getting
three to four hours four to five it's a
w
to me because these current joints
you're getting one to two
I think they can because if you put the
rug in uh silent and uh lower some specs
down on certain things you can get
actual juice out yeah the current switch
that we do have right now we already
know that my uh that Nintendo has been
throttling back the switch anyway we've
been yelling for a long time release the
true power of the Integra chip right and
if they ever did I mean it's shorter in
battery life what the fact of the matter
is that Nintendo switch is more capable
than people really think and and if
they're able to do the same thing with
the next one you're gonna throttle it
back and and you know allow them to play
the games that are decent you know yeah
we'll see we'll see look all I asked for
I know I'm still pieing this guy will
complete my dream
you know reintendo get back together
again would be please if so just all
right if you ain't gonna do
achieve this all right fine I would love
achievements you know I can I message
can I just want an online message I just
want to send a message to my friend I
would say attic I'm going today I just
want them
to just
integrate Discord to their system yeah
if you ain't going to do it put Discord
in your joint facts give us give us apps
Nintendo name facts if you ain't gonna
do it because I think the only thing
they have is like YouTube and that was
saying give us some apps put it just get
a deal with Discord because clearly you
don't you can't handle that let them run
and let us get our party chat on and
that could be the cross-platform joy and
I do think King is on to something you
know with the reason why the power is
very important is because they got the
10-year deal they got the 10-year deal
with the ABK and the card so I'm excited
I'm excited man look hey he's he's a car
got here cheating on his L.A listen I
got my allies from a big boy stuff but
you got to remember Nintendo still has
those exclusive and shout out to my man
Nintendo he's got a point I don't care
what nobody say 300 300 400 if that
Drake come with a Mario
a Mario card
is over
people could sit there and say we got
six kids but you know papa is this and
pop up this Mama's Papa switch y'all got
y'all I'm telling you bro that that it's
gonna move that their IPs move but I
think it's gonna sell a whole lot better
than
it's it's going to take over the crown
of the current handhelds that we do have
in the market now yeah we know we do
have a lot of high-end you know steam
decks and all this other stuff that's
out there but at the end of the day
Nintendo has the magic with the uh the
IPS VIPs right and if you're not Savvy
enough to learn how to do certain things
to make those IPS appear in other places
your only uh you know recourse is to get
a switch and whatever it's going to be
called I think Naman is the key problem
with the Wii U nobody knew what it was
yeah yeah man I think
key to
strategy of this Nintendo new Switch
is the name yeah the name and you said
it best what is the hook this time you
what is how you flipping it so objection
yeah no doubt that's all I got the last
time I get about it
from Super chats
you go ahead
I'm looking no doubt no doubt yo I'ma
tell y'all now nine to ten dollars we
need them achievements we need them
achievements two dollars from Danny
passion official now Nintendo will uh
run called native good for Microsoft
though okay we got a um world gold from
uh KJ wash 85 uh we got a two dollars
for trap from Nintendo Dawn the otaku if
they launched with my uh Mario Kart
price doesn't matter they have a two
dollar Super Chat for
by like 30 million yeah they got a five
dollar super trap Nintendo uh uh
Nintendo down the attacker Nintendo has
been out selling everyone with a hand
tied behind they back so power online
and no third party y'all not ready if
both are fixed and then we have a member
chat from tsws gaming Microsoft was like
Nintendo no disrespect but please get
some power to give you that call the
dominance new okay five dollar super
trap from four eyes
Malin Malone
Nintendo just can't do like the Wii U
and Confused customers and Publishers
plus they need to get storage to 128
gigabyte minimum okay storage gonna be
interesting good point last one on the
docket this is you attic I don't know if
you want me to set you up yeah you can
say that all right looks like uh read
pop in Esa the part weighs over E3 so um
yeah Pax organizer report pop will not
be working on future E3 events this is
according to gamesindustry.biz and um
looks like uh being a company and the
ESL announced um Esa has informed them
that the Los Angeles Convention Center
or will not be putting a show there on
2024 they have not canceled plans for a
2024 event but it's not going to take
place at that venue
um looks like the are they looking for a
complete um reinvention of the show for
225 and then re-pop pretty much said
that um was you know who started the
deal in 2020 for the deal said that um
the first effort to relaunch the event
failed to get off the ground and on the
planned 2023 show that was canceled this
the decision to end the relationship was
a mutual decision and then this was the
esa's president saying we appreciate
repop's partnership over the past 14
months support their ongoing efforts to
bring industry and fans together they
said um they want to continue to
evaluate and explore how to best serve
the video game industry and every aspect
they said they're looking forward to
sharing news about E3 in the coming
months and yeah so it was able to split
and I'm trying to see if there's any
other
um yeah they said uh as far as repops
final statements they said uh while we
will not be involved with the future of
e3 we can look forward to seeing its
Evolution and where the esa take it so
this is your topic added
uh I I I think that
the odds of ether coming back are pretty
slim yeah uh but it would be interesting
if instead of canceling it they pivoted
they're like we don't got to be in La
you know let's let's look other places
let's let's take this venue maybe to New
York or to you know Dallas in in Texas
or there's a there's a lot of other
bigger
places around the country that they
could take it to maybe get a vast Dill
do more marketing locally than they
usually do
I don't know uh you know it's not
looking good
um
maybe they'll still be around that time
all I know is
La the only reason they were able to be
successful is because they had the help
of the industry if they can't mend those
wounds and get people like PlayStation
and Xbox and Nintendo back to a degree
they could have a venue in New York for
free and still fail right because
we're the iron Lords podcast if E3 is in
New York where you guys are and
everywhere else is it not like where are
we going east coast where are we going
we going to LA because that is where the
bulk of the industry is going to be
what's the point in having an event if
XBox
Nintendo PlayStation EA Ubisoft
um
all these other places uh devolver
digital what's the point having an event
if they're not there yeah
E3 has never been to me has been the esa
E3 has been an event
a duration throughout the year which is
usually in the June where we all come
together we celebrate gaming we we go to
the conferences that's E3 the convention
was never E3 to me that the the E3 was
that time of the year where we all come
together we go out for drinks well you
guys go I don't drink we eat yeah we you
know we we watch these conferences we
fight our way to get into the Bethesda
conference that was E3 to me I feel like
Esa has never been E3 to me sure they
own The Branding but they've never been
E3 E3 was the whole week it was even
when EA play was off site did we ever go
to uh we had EA Plano we are at E3 it
was it was the event it wasn't yeah they
can do whatever they want
I'm snatching that name addict's name
for that convention for that duration in
La every June when when Microsoft goes
on stage when PlayStation
sometimes Go on stage when Nintendo has
their E3 Direct that's E3 forget all
that other foolishness they could take
that anywhere they want if the esa don't
get they stuff together and find a way
to mend those wounds and get those other
people back they can bring E3 back
anywhere around the country it's not
going to matter because they don't have
the help of the industry industry yeah
no it's a good point it's a very good
point King E3
near and dear to us we started a lot
there you know now we see him we pop and
Esa split and now the future will be
changing it's up in the air yeah
um the thing is
I always knew that you couldn't succeed
doing the same things that made you lose
and that's the definition of insanity
right you're gonna Double Down You're
gonna take more money you're gonna throw
it right back into the same thing into
the same way that you lost now
as marketing manager of IOP you and as a
individual that understand Trends and
knows where stuff goes and I can pretty
much predict and navigate through only
thing that you need in this lifetime is
capital and balls pause
um and if you have enough of both you're
able to
be daring enough to change something
I can tell ESA
that I know exactly what you did wrong
how you did it wrong and how to Pivot
and switch it what we doing
there's a I will never let this out
oh so anybody that's sitting there
trying to go get the tickets get free
cookies right now okay it's in here you
ain't gonna get it pay that man pay that
minute
yeah DSA look over the
me reach out to us reach out
I can change fundamentally
I could predict one of your changes
exactly I know you know it you know
exactly what it is saying it people in
the chat are saying so what one person I
say sauce I think I saw something okay I
could change it fix it and turn it into
exactly what you wanted it to be I
wanted to be that event you wanted to
turn it back into the mecca you wanted
to turn into something else and yellow
your ability to do so is there but your
willingness to look outside of the box
isn't Jeff is beating you
at your game but he knows how to move
better he knows how to navigate in this
current wave of digital
you guys are analog
you're fighting against the digital and
the digital guy is beating the snot out
of you you don't know how to recover
because everybody is looking over to how
successful the digital guy pivoted and
then saving money yeah you physical
analog entities are has turned it into
something that
and like addict said it used to be event
of the week what was going on in
Satellite circumference of what you had
going on and you benefited from all
those satellites around you
now those satellites are not there
you're standing there by yourself and
what do you yourself have to offer in
order to bring these satellites back to
entice them back to you you can't right
now because you don't know how to switch
it I do
now EA being E3 being dead I knew that
was going to happen
and it sucks because it's something that
is legacied into us as Gamers from
fundamentally from the beginning from
being ostracized uh from the event right
and and being shunned as far as
commoners until we were able to get
media to go inside to see what's going
in this you want to see what's behind
the Velvet Rope you want to see what's
all the magic about and you get inside
you we only got a chance to live in that
magic for probably four years facts
about four years four years happening
you know uh to get to these events to
see EA play to see you be soft off site
to see the PC award I mean the PC show
shout out to the Ubisoft pieces and mad
right bro yep to see like a Sony show to
see Nintendo's show to be there when
everything was rocking
everybody wants to know how to get that
old feel back now I want you to remember
this if you break up with somebody right
and you you and that individual don't
work
but you still have feelings for that
individual
you always got to remember what broke
y'all up to begin with
right so now if you choose to go back
with that individual
you have to figure out what led up to
the breakup what caused the breakup
why'd the breakup happen you have to
analyze the problem facts to eliminate
the problem in order to make what you
thought is successful succeeding even
further you don't go into this the old
relationship doing the same old things
because you will have the same results
so you must switch up I know how to
switch it up the switch up isn't that
hard but it's going to take Financial
effort and it's going to take a strength
and when I say balls I'm a guy uh I will
say that pause but um
it's just that's why I grew up in the
age a lack of a better word you got to
have the fortitude within yourself to be
able to withstand
the tide switching on you
it sucks anybody got a chance to
experience it's there but they have the
ability to Rise From the Ashes and I
know under immense pressure from Jeff
Jeff is doing his thing it looks like
it's an insurmountable odds for you to
do that but remember this Jeff now it
will look like from the outside Jeff has
did this only in two years two to three
years
no Jeff has had a long build up to this
and he was studying your flaws and your
weaknesses
and that's how he capitalized on it and
he was allowing to take those satellites
that you had around you and fix that you
want to get those connections back
You're Not Strong by yourself I feel
like I'll jump in you pretty much said a
lot of well I was going to say already
um I'm actually surprised that it didn't
work out with Reed Pop I thought repot
would be I don't even think there was an
opportunity to be honest with you I hope
that's not the case because lit like
they do all right I think what happened
is the pandemic happened and that just
took all the fuel out and it was like
look you know we couldn't actually give
this a shot uh you know I think because
they downsized uh repop used to do Pax
uh uh packs South they stopped doing
that right so I think that you know that
was that her raw to you know get back
into this swing of things and I think
after the pandemic happened they're like
we're going to focus on the stuff we
have left and nurture that I think it
was re-pop that pulled away I think it's
repop that pulled away
again I don't I'm not in these meetings
all I guess I'm surprised because
if you look at re-pop separate right
each year since pandemic you know has
slowly been easing right
they've been slowly clawing back and
it's getting bigger and it's getting
bigger like the packs East we go to
packs West you know it's so it's getting
bad it was a second building this time
they built for the whole Pax West app
you know over there in Seattle and when
I looked at that second building I'm
like oh you can put this whole thing
over here this thing is humongous right
so to me I I see it slowly trending back
for them right
I don't know what happened here but for
them to pull away when they initially so
early in the deal that's my thing you
didn't have one year of an event with
y'all working together yeah if it was
one year and it flopped that's why it
made me feel like after the pandemic
they're like look we got to focus on us
and I don't think I think that I'm just
I'm just gonna be real this I have no
evidence I'm just going on gut I think
that Esa is just stubborn and hard to
deal with I'm really starting to get to
that point because it's like I don't see
how you couldn't make this work what
Vision that you saw oh that you couldn't
make work that they got going on and
it's just like so so it almost tell you
why okay it didn't work with them
fundamentally
ESA
doesn't want to really work with the
public
fundamentally from the core you got to
look at the core like from fundamental
from the from the from the old school
core okay actually yeah from the
fundamentals they are still built that's
why they was doing what me and sovereign
fundamentally packs and repop is only
about the the correct only about the
public spectacle as far as the dress up
come through uh the rooms have the
public bathrooms you know uh all this I
know how to do something right they do
they they not know how to treat that
media bruh they not playing right so
when you have those two opposing thought
processes going in right we're gonna try
to uh tell you we need to make it a
bigger better packs we can turn this
into uh E3 event packs La we can have
this and we can have this
when the other person is introverted and
other and that person is extra
extroverted the introverted person is
going to shy away and going to give a
rebuff again
that's possible that's what I fell apart
no it could be it could be the only
reason why the only slight pushback I
have and you still could be right even
though with my push but with this
pushback is that
towards the end of day demise that last
year or two they was making fan you know
thing they were very fan you know fan
day and we're going to do this though
true and it could be for you right and
it could be four seconds that could be
the pivot that maybe they didn't like to
do and then they wasn't they like
charge it it was like a weird ending
they had before they conked out before
they tapped out but um look it's
interesting I'm just biased look I like
Reeboks so I just like yeah I can't make
it worth a repop like so I'm with addict
I don't think
I don't got much confidence or Esa on
their own what they gonna do I thought
your ID king of a packs you know La
packs would have been lit you know maybe
it was that maybe who get the headline
for the who knows who knows but yeah I
don't have much confidence I think what
you call it Jeff is out here killing
them we'll see and you know they still
seem committed to going to do it so
we'll see what that version of it here
would be crazy yeah
we talking all this smacks to another
building in L.A and they're like the The
Talk of the Town it's so little my thing
is this
the the thing that's gonna hurt them is
when they lost Microsoft
no big publisher third-party person
saying that I'm willing to show up to
your joint yeah and not only that they
like we could do it ourselves we don't
need you
so who Who you gonna showcase
other than mobile games indie game like
who who really is going to be the hook
to pull you away from everything else
that's the battle and I felt repot still
got the connections with everybody
like Jeff we don't know his black book
is crazy
right you got anybody could pull up on
the Jeff show you can have a super what
do you he got actors and actresses right
there like it's it's super honest with
you yeah I don't even think Jeff is
doing 100 with the stuff he wants to
like you know we see these it used to be
the Video Game Awards Microsoft would
announce some big title there but
they're not even doing that now so it's
just like you don't really see
PlayStation announce like brand new
stuff like at the end of the day
especially the platform holders they're
gonna and Microsoft's doing this a lot
more thank God they're gonna save their
best stuff for them for their shows for
their events and it's just like it's
hard to do these event things and you're
not a platform yeah because you have to
rely on third parties that nine times
out of ten what do they have with the
platforms marketing deals it's hard to
rely on us on a platform holder such as
Microsoft and Playstation to yo let me
get that let me get that first Fable
gameplay nah Jeff I want the first Fable
game for mice that's my stuff my dad's
work for that that's going on our
directs it's hard to get that so I had
to get that yeah so we'll see that's all
I got on it but yeah it look it's kind
of spooky to me that's what I got that's
right I think I think it gets better if
they're able if they're serious about
making it work
probably okay it's it's it's it's it's
it's it's not small
but it's stuff that can happen that can
change it and it can turn it into what
it's supposed to be everything is an
evolution if you stay stagnant and you
don't have any motion you're just going
to get over overrun you've got to have
motion you gotta constantly be moving
and elevating always content elevation
leads to expansion all right morons
while I chill in my man constant
elevation shorty mine over um no doubt
so um I think we're gonna get the super
chance we're gonna do the poll first
um
[Music]
we need external batteries that we could
buy for handheld gaming systems laptops
had slots where you could take the disk
drive out and replace with another
battery you want you want the external
slots game no you remember that with the
um a turbo Duo yeah I mean I know the
turbo Express with that faster battery
yo I'm bad that was the beefiest
handheld
could you plug it into the wall shut up
and play or you had to do the best no I
was able to plug it into Walmart I was
sitting next to the wall and play it
when I was like at the store and the TV
tuner the TV
I love the temporary Express shout out
to the Hue card and all that see if
these turbo espresso's on sale yeah but
I think that was it I know you were
talking but that was what I will take
the um pole all right so obviously it
has no been pulled for a while we start
one up again with the recent successful
launch of star field which aspect do you
consider the most impressive your
choices are eight one million one
million on Steam one million plus on
Early Access Premium Edition sales
B biggest Bethesda Game launch ever at 6
million players
C currently the top three most played
game on Xbox Live or D I don't care I
told y'all put respect on God how it's
there
those are the choices Rock the vote when
it goes up Salute to everybody in the
room appreciate the World wishes
appreciate the love I see a lot of DMS
behind the scene again for anyone I
didn't get back to you it will take me
some time your boy just pays it himself
you know what I'm saying resting but um
it's good to be back and again to speak
with my brothers and do what we love
doing it's always fun um addict to the
uh words to the people what you got
going on
oh you can catch me on Twitter at Lord I
apologize for the noise you know for
some reason I only asked for three four
hours a week and people decide to do
everything known to man in this room
when I need stuff done but yeah we we
had a a great time at Pax West you know
we got more uh more stuff in store for
you we got some big guests incoming uh
yo we big biggest guess we've ever had
and where we're trying man we're trying
and uh you know hopefully we'll have
some more stuff to share to you guys in
the next couple months we actually
you know we're thinking about going to
to more uh broadened places when it
comes to like events and stuff next year
so you know hopefully we'll we'll see
more on that
middle of next year but I want to thank
everyone for coming through we had up to
like what was like 950 people in here or
something like that nice it was a very
good show football on football Sunday
too we forgot today today is the debut
of football Sunday and they still kind
of maintain that is super impressive
yeah we used to run from this back in
the day yeah yeah I hate I hate that I
hate
yeah you like that 11 A.M you don't want
to go back no no
but uh we'll see you guys next week and
hopefully there'll be some stuff to talk
about because this week I feel like
people are either playing Starfield or
they're watching football there's not
like a lot to go on right now we badly
the Lord right now they gonna catch us
on the rebound
really facts and we got five dollar
Super Chat from Nintendo doll and you
talk to I see my name uh so we'll see
how this goes I don't feel like my money
is well spent when added
I literally just read the Super Chat so
do you want me you want me to talk and
you're over here
Super Chat
you can't be doing your neck like that
it's ridiculous yeah I don't like you
getting that into that anyway he said
yes yo he's stupid anyway shout out
Brothers
I like that so oh shout out he said I
prefer that yo yo yo country big said
addict stop that please
[Laughter]
soft talk Sunday
anyway Lord King we're gonna find people
find you what you got going on Sir oh
you can find me on Twitter that's King
David OTW listen do me a favor go on
Twitter to see those interviews that we
put up if you don't follow me follow me
now those videos is up there so you can
check that out also go to
lordsofgaming.net where we have more
videos more interviews what we did at
Pax West I always walk away from these
shows feeling I didn't do enough I
didn't do more I can always do more if
you're not walking away from these shows
feeling that you you've done the most
um then I think you need to go back in I
want to give a special shout out to all
the people that I did see their boots on
the ground feet that was there I saw the
whole uh women's at gaming
um their uh parents level one
they had a community room and I'm going
to tell you
that's that's what you're supposed to be
doing you're supposed to be connecting
to your community I wish I would have
known ahead of time we found out really
at the last we found out the airport
well I found out at the airport that
they had a community room I would have
loved to have known a little bit sooner
so we could have done more things but
attic and I made it up there to that
community room to show support uh shout
out to uh Baron Baron from uh level one
gaming you're looking at her bad guys
names level of grime confusion is
something beautiful to see and he
mispronounced he's at these shows he's
working as hard as he possibly can and
he's holding his team down shout out to
Colt uh that was there Colt was there
with his family and he was working at
the same time so it's very hard to
balance family and fun but he was doing
both and you know in business and it was
it was something great to see
um uh Nintendo Joshua oh that man yeah
he pulled up on us good day and then
that was great that was with him yeah I
wish we would have known that they was
going to be there yeah you understand
could you imagine uh everybody up inside
the community room bringing our
communities together having these
conversations you know called everybody
we got to do better as a community we're
not separate in order to grow everybody
must come together all right so you
can't look over at somebody else and
saying they're doing this and you're not
doing this to attach and grow together
we all got to do it together yeah all
right um Philly Eagles fan oh Philly yes
that's what I'm talking about hello
Philly Eagles fan was there when we had
12 people he has been riding with us
Pax West he pulled up on me he was
texting me in the DMS and he found out
where we was at and that's that level of
comfortability that we extend to you
guys we're we're we come to you with
respect No Malice we expect
we could have been like a lot of these
other podcasts you know we we took the
homie to dinner with us like yeah like
he was he was he was rocking with us
shout out to to Kai shout out to a lot
of other people I can't name your names
but you know who you are shout out to
Drew you always trying to figure out how
I know everything yeah
all the way to the end we had over 900
people watching I appreciate that on a
football Sunday I don't hold your
hostage anymore but I also want y'all to
know we do have a patreon and then that
patreon we're trying to give you a value
a lot of our stuff are we going to be
feeding straight through the patreon so
go to r r with the Lords that's there
addicts doing reactions to a lot of
shows I'm doing reactions to a lot of
shows we have more stuff that we're
going to add to the patreon to show you
that value and keep on the lookout for
our uh Kickstarter that's gonna go up
and you guys get a chance to know what's
going to happen with that we also have
Partnerships that we're working with in
the background oh yeah listen guys if if
you didn't get your Volari pillow I want
you to go out and go get yourself a
Volari pillow go check that out it's a
wonderful pillow to have in it and see
if you don't have the flavor that you're
looking for you're just holding out
stick around we've got stuff in the
middle stuff working for you guys
definitely love what we got coming up
but um but thank you for all the support
without you guys we will not be able to
do anything that we do facts we
appreciate your time your efforts your
likes your shares your super chats
everything that you guys do we
appreciate it thank you so much no doubt
yeah salute salute again everybody that
pulled up on us on on Pax so many people
and the developers and and just you know
being out there and so many people shout
out to my LS7 fan who also pulled up you
know yeah it was so dope for people yeah
oh y'all man shout out to the homie Noli
Nolan nerd cast so many people N64 jobs
we said I got we we gotta tell the story
real quick
and King were walking on one of those
rooftops cameras
yeah we're on we're on our way to Kai
because you know we have a little uh get
together
and we're just walking through and all I
hear is Lord
just like that
like that and he's just looking
menacingly across but I'm standing there
with his girl and he has it has his
nipple out
his Ryu it was a fighting game cross
flavor continue look at him he's
apologizingly trying to explain the
story I looked at god with his nipple
and I got it and he goes he goes
Lord God
I love you so I'm like yo you want a
picture with him yeah hey I don't know I
laugh again the level of enthusiasm
radiating through his body he's sitting
there with one hard nipple and he's like
that's my name
just like that so he gets over there to
take a picture I'm standing there with
my camera I'm like I got you he goes no
kid
[Music]
ridiculous shout out to my man Casper
Casper J LSM FIB I had bro that was
loved I got both pictures you got it and
I got pictures from the front I got both
pictures
easily Miss people names yeah yeah those
are the people that we met so don't ever
take anything as a slice
and then also again we're moving and oh
shout out about Patrick Grand uh Sarah
naughty dog you know EA was in the
building response was in the building
his beautiful wife um and Vera Bagel in
them um so many people anybody that
forgot please forgive us but it was just
so cool to get the love and honestly for
people who knew my situation they knew
how you know it's important to see me
and and just you know being okay and
stuff like that so the love was felt and
uh yeah yeah it was dope so shout out to
Pack's West fun trip wish we could have
longer it was on limited time and then
shout out to y'all for holding me down
not allowing me to push myself crazy
taking half days going back to the hotel
to rest because I'm still not 100 yet
salute to that but I do want to say
stay tuned tomorrow tomorrow stay tuned
we got some exclusive dose of check
every platforming I want y'all knowing
Lords of gaming.net
channel on IOP we got explosive doses
right we hitting y'all in the head
because we that we them dudes we got
stuff cooking and it's gonna be fun and
like addict said we got things other
things cooking later we got some fun
things this is the time it's time to
rock with IOP right now let them go you
know what I'm saying it's the time this
ain't the time to be in your feelings
it's the time to be with IOP cause we in
these streets we giving it immediately
we boost to the ground and uh look we
work hard we work hard and and I'm not
and I really talk my talk but look at
the end of the day you know we feel that
the quality that we're given can go up
against anybody and it's just about the
love of these games and how passionate
we are how much we care about this and
uh yeah I hope you guys enjoy it that's
all I got addict um let's get these kind
of super chats and then us rolling on
out here uh what Super Chat did you read
last
um I've read I think you got uh rubber
knob okay okay we got a five dollars
good morning Lord starfit is the bomb or
should I call it
Starscream oh boy I got a five dollar
super shop
a blessed day to everyone in the realm
that is a great show Lords hope today's
discussion goes oh this song's inner
thighs
oh yeah that's just the phone
[Music]
why are we discussing songs
I come from phone stars and when I put
up oh wait instant phone okay what is
that gotta do with songs in the thighs
they want to attach it to something
and then and then you know put put those
logos in the chat first Cipher he he
gave to five of you guys membership oh
no then we got up to five dollar Super
Chat go Spartans six six one IOP is my
Sunday event that takes priority oh no
somebody says Southern bell addict you
know he's he's sounds like
um what was that Paul Bearer yeah yeah
yeah a little Paul Bearer a little
southern belle no doubt oh sorry to go
solvers in the chat why this addict
sound like the child but yo yo old man
time on you for using the verbiage so so
mind your business
come here Chris
foreign
see y'all next week I'm sending you guys
the wandering Dutch by the way oh yes
I'm sitting here wandering Dutch uh go
in there and type IOP raid that's what
we want in there oh I got something
coming up with Dutch too and the patreon
oh wait enjoy your Sunday
[Music]
all right
thank you